चलिए तो हम आ चुके हैं लाइव फाइनली एंड
लेट मी सेंड द अनाउंसमेंट हियर ओके ओके
चलिए तो हम लाइव आ चुके हैं आई थिंक आई एम
लाइव लेट मी सी सब कुछ सही है क्या एक बार
ऑडियो वीडियो में देख लेता हूं थोड़ा वेट
कीजिए जस्ट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट
लेट म सी द ऑडियो एंड वीडियो ऑडियो वीडियो
सही है सबके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
सबको सबको नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग क्या हाल चाल
है भाई साहब सबके क्या हाल चाल है
बढ़िया ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही जा रही है ना
भाई एकदम बढ़िया से कोई दिक्कत सक्कत तो
नहीं आ रही
है कोई दिक्कत सक्कत तो नहीं आ रही है सब
सही है बढ़िया चलो गुड इवनिंग सबको कितने
लोग आ चुके हैं सभी लोग अरे गुड इवनिंग तो
बोल दिया करो यार विश करने में क्या जाता
है विश तो कर दिया करो भाई आपके विश के
लिए तो यार हम यहां आते हैं आप विश नहीं
करोगे तो बड़ा बुरा लगता है यार बहुत बुरा
लगता
है तो यार गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते सलाम सत श्री
अकाल केम छो वाना कम सब
बढ़िया चलिए चलिए बढ़िया सबका एकदम
बढ़िया चलिए मैं एकदम बढ़िया मैं बढ़िया
अब
देखो अरे गुड नाइट मत बोलो भाई
चलो
बढ़िया अच्छा बक बाउंडी जो सीरीज चल रही
है पहले मुझे यह बताइए आप लोग अभी जो यह
हमारा सीरीज चल रहा है य हमारी जो क्लासेस
चल रही है आपको इससे बेनिफिट हो रहा है
कुछ या बस ऐसे ही क्लासेस आप ले रहे हैं
जस्ट यूजुअल आर यू गेटिंग बेनिफिटेड कुछ
फायदा मिल रहा है कुछ सीखने को मिल रहा है
कुछ चेंज लग रहा है आपके में कुछ नई चीजें
पता चल रही है समथिंग समथिंग या बस ऐसे ही
आप कर रहे हो क्लासेस बता दो मुझे सभी लोग
बताइए आई एम सीइंग द मैसेजेस इंडियन सैलेश
सब लोग
बताइए कैसा लग रहा है आपको कुछ प्रोडक्टिव
लग रहा है सच में मतलब मुझे भी रिव्यू तो
लेना पड़ेगा ना खुद का भी मैं ट्रेनिंग
अगर दे रहा हूं या फ्री में क्लासेस ले
रहा हूं तो उसके रिव्यूज मुझे चाहिए
आपसे ओके यस सर हो रहा है ठीक
है बेनिफिट हो रहा है ठीक है
चलो बेनिफिट हो रहा है तो मेरा यह क्लास
लेना बिल्कुल
सक्सेसफुल मैं मानूंगा नहीं होता तो शायद
कुछ मैं देखता फिर बेनिफिट ठीक है बहुत
सीखने को मिल रहा है डोंट स्टॉप इट ठीक है
ओके ओके कौन सा अटैक्स अक्षय कौन से
अटैक्स सीखने है सीखने आपको बताइए
अटैक्स कौन से सीखने हैं तो चलिए आज के
क्लास में एंड मैप को खत्म करते हैं एंड
मैप को स्वाहा बोलते हैं और आज की क्लास
बहुत ज्यादा देर नहीं चलेगी बट यस जितना
चलेगा आपके लिए बहुत प्रोडक्टिव होने वाला
है बहुत कुछ आपको सीखने को मिलने वाला है
आज की क्लास में बहुत कुछ जानकारी मिलने
वाली है अपने दोस्तों के बीच शेयर करते
रहिए इन क्लासेस को क्योंकि आपका सपोर्ट
ही है जो हमें 10000 डिफन स्टस तक लेकर
आया है नेक्स्ट माइलस्टोन 25000 का है एंड
आई नो बहुत बड़ी बात नहीं है आपके रहते
हुए तो मुझे कोई टेंशन ज्यादा है नहीं
सर बहुत ज्यादा हो रहा है बस बाउंट अभी तक
नहीं मिली कोई बात नहीं बाउंट भी मिलेगी
टेंशन नहीं लेने का पूरे
वो मिलता जाएगा एंड बीच-बीच में मैं क्या
करूंगा आपको बग बाउंट के टिप्स की वीडियोस
भी डालने की मैं सोच रहा हूं बीच-बीच में
अभी मैं स्टार्ट करूंगा कुछ दिनों से तो
आप बताइए कैसा है ये अ कैसा कैसा मैंने
सोचा है कि लाइव में नहीं टिप्स एज अ
वीडियो फॉर्म आपको बग बाउंट छोटे टिप्स
बताता चलूं ये शॉट्स के थ्रू भी हो सकती
हैं या तो लाइव वीडियो सॉरी रिकॉर्डेड
वीडियो के फॉर्म में भी हो सकती है मतलब 5
से 10 मिनट के अंदर 10 मिनट के अंदर के
वीडियो में वो आपको पर्टिकुलर जो जो आपके
टिप्स हैं ट्रिक्स हैं कुछ बग बाउंटीज के
वन लाइनर्स वगैरह किस तरीके से यूज करना
है कौन सी वन एबिलिटी को कैसे आप बहुत ही
इजली फाइंड कर सकते हो या ट्राई कर सकते
हो एटलीस्ट ओबवियसली ट्राई कर सकते हो ये
सारी चीजें वी विल बी डीलिंग विद दैट तो
आप मुझे बता
दीजिए ठीक
है धन्यवाद नॉलेज
बेस ठीक है ठीक है ओके ठीक
है ठीक है प्लीज डोंट स्पैम स्पैम करोगे
तो आपको मजबूरी में मुझे टाइम आउट करना
पड़ेगा मैं चाहता किसी को भी नहीं हूं
टाइम आउट करना ठीक है बट प्लीज डोंट स्पैम
एक बार आप चैट में लिख दो एंड
दैट्ची है आ जाएगी भाई आ जाएगी टेंशन मत
लो डीएनएस के ऊपर इर वीडियो भी आ जाएगा
ठीक
है ठीक है आ जाएगा टेंशन ना
लो सबर मेरे को टारगेट सिलेक्ट करने में
प्रॉब्लम हो रही है लक्षित जैन लक्षित
आपने 110 पर आपने स्टार्टिंग के वीडियोस
नहीं देखे हैं अगर आपने स्टार्टिंग के
वीडियोस देखे होते तो आपको टारगेट सिलेक्ट
करने में प्रॉब्लम नहीं आती यह मैं गारंटी
के साथ कह सकता हूं मतलब कोई भी यहां पर
जो है जो भी शुरू से बग बाउटी की वीडियोस
देख रहे हैं आप लोग ही बताइए कि टारगेट
सिलेक्शन के ऊपर मैंने क्लास में बताया है
कि नहीं बहुत डिटेल में और बहुत आराम से
बताया है है
ना
तो आप लोग भी बता दीजिए ना लक्षित को आप
अगर एकदम से रेगुलर व्यूअर है तो आपको
मिली होगी टॉपिक यार मैंने पूरा डिटेल में
बताया हुआ है फर्स्ट सेकंड क्लासेस देखो
आप फर्स्ट और सेकंड जो क्लास है उसको देखो
एक बार यू विल गेट पक्का
से ठीक है
चलिए ओके सो गाइस स्टार्ट करते हैं आज का
सेशन हम लक्षित एक बार प्लीज फर्स्ट एंड
सेकंड डे का जो वीडियो है वो देखिए ठीक
है
वो देखिए प्लीज आपका क्लियर हो जाएगा
लक्षित पक्का श्यर है फर्स्ट एंड सेकंड डे
का पूरा वीडियो देखिएगा एक एक
लाइन जय हो जय हो जय हो सर की जय हो भाई
आपकी भी जय हो बहुत-बहुत जय हो आपकी ठीक
है चलिए तो और
अपने अपने जो आपकी जो है ना डी मोटिवेशन
नहीं लानी है आपके अंदर मोटिवेट रहना है
बग बाउंट हंटर बनना है प्रो बग बाउंट हंटर
बनना है तुम लोग सभी लोग मुझे बताओ आपको
कोई भी आप बग बाउंट हंटिंग पहले भी करते
हो या कुछ भी करते हो या न्यू हो कुछ भी
उससे मतलब नहीं है यू वांट टू बिकम अ प्रो
बग बाउंट हंटर राइट है ना तो सभी लोग चैट
में बोलो लिखो आई वांट टू बिकम अ प्रो बग
बाउंट हंटर अभी बाउंट मिल रही है कि नहीं
स्वैग मिल रहा है कि नहीं इससे कोई मतलब
नहीं है हम वैलिड बग खोज के निकालेंगे
किसी भी हाल में आई वांट टू बिकम अ प्रो
बग बाउंट हंटर ये लिखो चैट में ये अंदर
में होना चाहिए अगर ये तुम्हारे अंदर नहीं
है तो सच में नहीं बनोगे मेनिफेस्ट किया
करो पता है मेनिफेस्टेशन इज वेरी वेरी
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग अगर मेनिफेस्टेशन
अगर करते हो बढ़िया से ना तो इंपॉसिबल भी
पॉसिबल हो जाता है मेनिफेस्टेशन का मतलब
होता है कि एक तरह से एक जो चीज आपको
चाहिए ना उसके लिए ही बार-बार बोलना और
सोचना उसके बारे में ही सोचना उसको ही
चीजें उसी को एग्जीक्यूट करना उसी को लेके
चीजों चीजें करना काम करना वो
मेनिफेस्टेशन होता है एंड वो अगर आप करने
लगे ना सोचने लगे हर एक एक ही चीज बार-बार
वो चीज होके ही रहेगी आपके लाइफ में तो वो
करना है ए बनना है है ना है ना बस सिंपल
सी बात
है यस सो सभी लोग बग बाउंट हंटर बनना है
तो बनना है प्रो बग बाउटी हंटर बनना है
भाई सीधा बग बाउटी हंटर नहीं बनना है अभी
बेस आपका तैयार हो रहा है अभी तो आपका कुछ
भी नहीं याद रखिएगा दिस इज जस्ट वी आर
जस्ट ट्राइट आई एम जस्ट ट्राइट मेक योर
बेस स्ट्रांग वो बेस स्ट्रांग हो जाए एंड
आप ऑटोमेटिक थो उस जब रास्ते पे आ जाओगे
ना यू विल ऑटोमेटिक बी रनिंग मुझे फिर कुछ
नहीं करने की जरूरत पड़ेगी ऑटोमेटिक आप
भागोगे दौड़े दौड़ो ग ठीक है या ग्रेट
तेजस मारिया डाक जिग्नेश ठीक है बहुत
बढ़िया नॉलेज बेस बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया ओके मौला
बढ़िया ओके ग्रेट सबको बहुत बढ़िया चलिए
आप सभी लोग बनेंगे भी टेंशन नहीं लेना है
ठीक
है या
आपको बनना है तो बनना है मुझे बनाना है तो
बनाना है सिंपल सा सिंपल सा फंडा है ठीक
है बस और कुछ फंडा होना ही नहीं चाहिए ठीक
है और कुछ नहीं चलिए तो चलिए स्टार्ट करते
हैं आज का सेशन ये हमारा डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का लिंकडन पेज है डेनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी लिंकन पे जाके सर्च कर लीजिएगा
आपको हमारा पेज मिल जाएगा ये हमारी एथिकल
हैकिंग की एक कंप्लीट एथिकल हैकिंग का
कोर्स है जिसका एक्सेस आपको वेब और
एंड्राइड पप दोनों पे मिलता है आप इस
यूआरएल पे आके इसमें इनरोल कर सकते हैं
एंड हम जो आज जो स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं जो
हमारा आज का टॉपिक है वो बहुत ही एक
शानदार टॉप है जो प्रीवियस टॉपिक था हमारा
उसी का यह सेकंड पार्ट आप बोल सकते हैं
ठीक है क्योंकि ये सेकंड एंड लास्ट पार्ट
है तो एनम को आज हम खत्म करेंगे एन मैप द
एंड ठीक है अब एन मैप जो है मैं इतना दो
क्लासेस में क्यों बताया आपको एन मैप को
दो क्लासेस में लेकर मैं क्यों आया इसके
सबसे ब इसकी सबसे बड़ी रीजन क्या है ना कि
हम हमेशा डोमस पर फोकस करते हैं ऑलवेज वी
ऑलवेज फोकस ऑन डोमस एंड हम पोर्ट्स पे
फोकस ही नहीं कर पाते जो डोमेन जो भी आपका
वेब सर्वर है ना उसके ऊपर बहुत सारे
पोर्ट्स रन कर रहे होते हैं
65535 सर्विसेस रन कर रही होती है हम उन
सर्विसेस को ना छोड़ देते हैं नेगलेक्ट कर
देते हैं इग्नोर कर देते हैं एंड ये सबसे
बड़ी गलती है तो लास्ट की क्लास में मैंने
आपको बताया था कि ए मैप का यूज करके कैसे
आप ओपन पोर्ट्स के सर्विसेस के बारे में
पता कर सकते हैं बहुत सिंपल सा तरीका था
एंड उसके भी पहले मैंने आपको बताया हुआ था
ये चीज कि ओपन पोर्ट्स कैसे फाइंड कर सकते
हैं मास स्कैन नाबू जैसे सुपर टूल्स का
यूज करके ठीक है तो आज हम एन मैप का कुछ
और भी चेहरा देखने वाले हैं ए मैप को और
भी थोड़ा डीप लेकर जाने वाले हैं सीखने
वाले हैं समझने वाले हैं दो-तीन टूल्स को
और टेक्निक्स को कंबाइन करने वाले आज का
मोटिव यही है तो आज के वीडियो में बहुत
चीज पता चलेगी आपको प्लीज आज के क्लास को
पूरा एंड तक देखिए मजा ही मजा आएगा मजा ना
आए तो मैं आप
सबको सबको एक एक रुपए दूंगा गारंटी के साथ
यू कैन कांटेक्ट अस एंड गेट योर रिवर्ड
अगर मजा ना आए
तो ठीक है चलिए
तो सबसे पहले गाइस सबसे पहले क्या करते
हैं सर आई थिंक क्या बारबार मैसेज मत करो
यार सर आई थिंक अबाउट बिकमिंग फुल टाइम बग
हंटर बट मुझे एआई की टेंशन बहुत ऐसा कुछ
एआई ओ आई कुछ नहीं करेगा ठीक है टेंशन मत
लो ए आईवाई कुछ नहीं आपका कर रहा है कुछ
नहीं होने वाला आपका एआई वाई सर रियली
एप्रूव्ड फर फ्री न थैंक यू सो मच वंस
अगेन जैस्पर द टॉम थैंक यू जैस्पर थैंक यू
अगर आपको लगता है आई एम डूइंग समथिंग एंड
मुझे इसके बदले में भी मिल ही रहा है आप
लोगों का सपोर्ट मिल रहा है आप लोगों का
ऐसे सब्सक्राइबर्स मिल रहे हैं मुझे एंड
मुझे आप लोगों का एक कम्युनिटी मिल रहा है
इससे बड़ी बात कुछ भी नहीं है एंड मैं
मैंने एक चीज और सोचा है कि शुड आई आप
बताइए एवरीवन प्लीज रिस्प शुड आई मेक अ
whatsapp.app ग्रुप फॉर बग बाउंट ग्रुप की
मैं बात कर रहा हूं जहां सब एक दूसरे से
बात कर पाए अपनी अपनी टिप्स को शेयर कर
पाए अपनी अपनी जर्नी को शेयर कर पाए बग
बाउंट में वोह क्या कर रहे हैं वो शेयर कर
पाए कोई किसी को असिस्ट कर पाए किसी को
नहीं पता उसको उसको वो समझा पाए या सम सम
टाइम्स लाइक हमारी टीम भी आपके साथ ही
रहेगी ऐसा कुछ यू वांट ग्रुप टाइप का कुछ
हां आपस में वही बात है
कर लेते हैं लोग एंड अलग-अलग तरह के स्कैम
और स्पैम करते हैं तो वो चीज t ग्रा प हम
बचा सकते हैं
राइट चलिए ओके आई विल इफॉर्म यू अगर कुछ
ऐसा होगा तो आपको इफॉर्म कर दिया जाएगा
ठीक है चलिए तो अब हम अपने मेन टॉपिक प
वापस आ जाते हैं सो डोमस को हम फोकस कर
देते हैं पोर्ट्स को हम बिल्कुल भूल जाते
हैं बट पोर्ट्स आर समथिंग दैट इज वेरी मच
इंपॉर्टेंट इन एन्यूमरेशन बग बाउंट रिकॉन
स्कैनिंग व्हाट एवर यू से मैं स्कैनिंग को
या एन्यूमरेशन को भी रिकॉन में ही डालता
हूं क्योंकि वो रिकॉन का ही पार्ट एक आप
मान सकते हैं चलिए अब यहां पे हम चलते हैं
सबसे पहले तो हम अपने एक प्लेटफार्म पे
चलते हैं एंड लेट्स गो टू बग क्राउड हम
यहां से बग क्राउड पे चलते हैं और एक
टारगेट ले लेते हैं पहले ठीक है तो ब बग
क्राउड पे चलते हैं एंड प्रोग्राम्स पे
चलते हैं यहां से आप कोई भी टारगेट ले
सकते हैं या तो आप
ले लेते हैं
[संगीत]
चलो बीएसएफ बीएएसएफ क्या है य बीएसएफ क्या
है देख लेते एक बार बीएसएफ क्या है यह ी
क्रिएट केमिस्ट्री
बीएसएफ कलर रिपोर्टर ऑटोमोटिव ओम कोटिंग्स
ओके ठीक है इससे रिलेटेड कोई कंपनी है
इनका रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर है
इन्वेस्टिगेट ल रिपोर्ट ठीक हैव य फा प्जम
ठीक है ये ईमेल करना है ईमेल अस
एट बीएसएफ रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर अच्छा
इनका ईमेल आईडी शायद ओपन हो जाएगा ईमेल
ओपन हो जाएगा ठीक है तो इस पर हम ईमेल
आईडी ईमेल कर सकते हैं एंड यहां पे इनका
कोई स्कोप वगैरह कुछ ऐसा नहीं है सिंपली
क्या है कोई सा भी आपको लेबिलिटी मिलता है
आप मिल जाए इन्होंने बहुत ज्यादा वो नहीं
किया है ये हॉल ऑफ फेम बना दिया इन्होंने
हर साल का ये 2020 17 18 ऐसे 19 ऐसे करके
तो बढ़िया है ठीक है तो
यस यस यस यस यस
चलिए तो इसी को हम ए टारगेट ले लेते हैं
तो टारगेट में हम क्या कर देते हैं बीएसएफ
इसके होम पेज पर आ जाते पहले तो एंड व्हाट
इज द वेबसाइट
bf.com ठीक है तो
bf.com इसको हम यहां
से सॉरी यहां से कॉपी कर लेते हैं ठीक है
अब चलो अब हम एप का यूज करने देखो अब एप
का यूज तुम अलग-अलग तरीके से कर सकते हो
तुम्हें कहीं से भी आईपी एड्रेस लेकर आना
है वैलिड आईपी एड्रेस वर्किंग आईपी एड्रेस
टीपी सर्वर वाली आईपी एड्रेस जिस पर
यूजुअली ए 443 पोर्ट आपका चल रहा है मतलब
एक्सेसिबल हो दैट वुड बी मच बेटर नहीं भी
एक्सेसिबल हो फॉर बिडेन हो या कुछ ऐसा तो
भी आप ट्राई आउट तो कर ही सकते हो ना कौन
सी सर्विस चल रही है क्या चल रही है पता
तो चला लगा ही सकते हो एनम का यूज हम करते
क्यों है
भाई पोर्ट स्कैन करने के लिए टू फाइंड च
सर्विसेस आर रनिंग ऑन पोर्ट्स ठीक है
च सर्विसेस आर वल्नरेबल
वल्नरेबल एंड ओल्ड ठीक है कैन वी
एक्सप्लोइट दोज
सर्विसेस इफ
यस वैलिड
बग इफ
नो मूव टू अदर टारगेट सिंपल सिंपल अब ये
देखो अब एमफ से हम क्या करते हैं आईपी को
तो स्कैन करते ही है आईपी सॉरी एन मैप से
हम पोर्ट की स्कैनिंग तो करते ही हैं
लेकिन पोर्ट की स्कैनिंग किसकी किसकी आईपी
एड्रेस की भी कर सकते हैं या डोमेन की भी
कर सकते हैं याद रखिएगा आईपी एड्रेस की कर
सकते हैं डोमेन की कर सकते हैं आईपी रेंज
की कर सकते हैं सीआईडीआर नोटेशंस के साथ
कर सकते हैं किसी भी तरह का इनपुट दे सकते
हैं एंड ये हमारा काम कर देता है एम ये
काम करता है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग का वि सर्विस
आर रनिंग क्या वो सर्विसेस वल्नरेबल या
आउटडेटेड है क्या हम उनको एक्सप्लोइट कर
सकते हैं क्या अगर हम एक्सप्लोइट कर पाए
तो एक वैलिड बग होगा नहीं कर पाए तो दूसरे
टारगेट की तरफ बढ़ी है सिंपल सी चीज है अब
हम क्या करते हैं हमने ये टारगेट चूज कर
लिया bsf.com ठीक है बीएसएफ ये लाइव
टारगेट है bsf.com हमने इसको चूज किया अब
हम क्या करते हैं हम सडन को ओपन करते हैं
चलो भैया सडन लेट्स लॉग इन सडन चलो लॉग इन
हो गया अब यहां पे हम सडन की चीटशीट यूज
करेंगे लेट्स ओपन सडन चीटशीट कोई सी भी
सडन की चीटशीट ओपन कर लेते हैं एंड यहां
पे ये चीटशीट है इसमें हम होस्ट नेम वाली
चीटशीट का होस्ट नेम वाला जो हमारा फिल्टर
है वो यूज कर लेते हैं होस्ट नेम वेबसाइट
के लिए कर लेते हैं तो यहां डालते हैं
होस्ट नेम एंड यहां डाल देते हैं bsf.com
होस्ट नेम bf.com ये हमने डाल दिया ठीक है
चलिए अब हम क्या करते हैं एंटर करते हैं
लेट्स सी लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग शफल
डियस काम नहीं कर रहा है ट्राई कीजिए अगर
नहीं कर रहा है तो मूव टू सम अदर टूल अगर
कोई टूल काम नहीं कर रहा है यू कैन मूव टू
सम अदर टूल ठीक है क्या आ रहा है लॉगइन टू
सर्च फिल्टर यूज सर्च फिल्टर क्यों भाई
लॉगिन नहीं है क्या
हमारा लेट्स
फ्रीलोड ओके ये आई थिंक लॉग आउट हो चुका
है मिस्टर
[संगीत]
परफेक्ट ओके अब यह पासवर्ड यार बड़ा
मुश्किल है यार यह पासवर्ड मुझे लेना
पड़ेगा एंड दिस पासवर्ड आई कैन नॉट शो यू
गाइस मैं पासवर्ड थोड़ी ना दिखा दूंगा आप
लोगों को तो मैं देखता हूं फोन पे एंड
यहां से टाइप करना पड़ेगा मुझे क्योंकि
मैं सामने मेल तो खोलूंगा पासवर्ड के लिए
क्यों पासवर्ड चाहिए क्या आपको पासवर्ड
देखना है आप लोगों को नहीं ना बोलो देखना
है तो मैं दिखा ही देता हूं बोलो पासवर्ड
चाहिए तो बोलो मैं दे देता हूं मैं तो
बहुत सिंपल सा आदमी हूं भाई मैं पासवर्ड
शेयर करता रहता हूं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है तो
मैं पासवर्ड डाल देता
हूं हम ये क्या पासवर्ड होगा
यार पताही नहीं चलता यार कुछ-कुछ आई में
और एल में कई बार कंफ्यूजन होता है बहुत
बड़ी वाली
आई होप कि मैं सही डाल रहा हूं जो भी
पासवर्ड डाला है मैंने एक बार में हो जाए
अबे सो मिस्टर परफेक्ट
007 वही जिसका डर है वही
हुआ इस बार मैं शायद सही डालूंगा लेट्स
सी इस बार सही नहीं हुआ तो मैं तो
मैं हैकिंग छोड़ दूंगा चलो ये इस बार सही
है बिल्कुल सही है अरे सही हो गया सही डल
गया तब मैंने बोला है ठीक है चलो बढ़िया
हां पासवर्ड तो सही है पासवर्ड डॉट डॉट
डॉट डॉ ऐसे करके ओके तो मैंने डाल लिया
मोबाइल से देख के कर लिया अब यहां पे आ
जाते हैं अब यहां पे हम होस्ट नेम वाली
चीज डाल देते हैं होस्ट नेम होस्ट नेम
bsf.com ठीक है ये हमने डाल दिया हमारी
टारगेट का जो यूआरएल है वो डाल दिया ठीक
है अब यहां पे हम सर्च सच कर लेते हैं
ओके होप टू गेट समथिंग सो वी सर्च दियार
एंड हमने जब सर्च किया गाइस तो हमें यहां
पे
5221 रिजल्ट्स मिले और मुझे डाउट हो रहा
है कि यह एक ऐसा प्रोग्राम है जिस जो कोई
बग बाउटी प्लेटफॉर्म पे भी नहीं है ऐसा
कुछ ये हमें
नहीं है इसका मतलब यह है तो अब रिलेटेड
कौन है तो हमें देखना पड़ेगा थोड़ा सा यह
भी हम देख लेंगे बट थोड़ा हम फिल्टरिंग का
भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं अब जैसे देखो यहां पे
लेफ्ट साइड में तुम आओगे तो यहां पे बहुत
सारी फिल्टरिंग है टॉप पोर्ट्स टॉप
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन टॉप प्रोडक्ट्स ये सब टॉप
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऐसे करके और मान लो मुझे
टॉप पोर्ट्स वाले हैं इस पे मान लो पोर्ट
के थ्रू फिल्टर करना है कुछ या वो कर सकते
हो या तो हम सामने यहां पे देखेंगे बीएसएफ
वाली कुछ है क्या अ यहां कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां कुछ भी नहीं है अ नॉट बीएसएफ नथिंग
इनवैलिड यूआरएल इनवैलिड
यूआरएल व्ट इ
दिस यह है अन का कुछ है अन क्लाउड का है
कुछ यह लेकिन है यह बीएसएफ को यह खा
बीएसएफ डिजिटल सोल्यूशन जी एम बीएच यह
इनका ही है क्या डिजिटल सलूशन पता नहीं
यार इनका है कि है भी कि नहीं
है यूआरएल तो वही है
हालाकि यूआरएल सेम सो इ देनी अबाउट सेक्शन
ये वही है यार अबाउट नहीं करते ना तो
दिक्कत हो जाती है बीएसएफ ओनली बीएसएफ रखा
है ओके यहां पे यूआरएल में यहां पे
इन्होंने दे रखा है ए पोटल स्डेड bf.com
तो इनका हो सकता है यह तो लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज देयर ऑन दिस
पेज एक्सेप्ट एंड चलो इसका ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
देख लेते हैं ये क्या है यह बीएसएफ पीपीओ
डोंट स्टॉप हाफ वे गो फॉर द टॉप एपिक
जर्नी य क्या है ओके व्हाट एवर इट इज अ
कुछ पेज है यहां पे मैं क्या करता हूं इस
आईपी को यहां से कॉपी कर लेता
हूं लेट्स कॉपी द आईपी लेट्स ओपन आवर मशीन
क्लाउड मशीन क्लाउड मशीन ओबवियसली मैं
डिजिटल ओसन यूज़ करता हूं यहां मैंने ओपन
कर रखा है डिजिटल ओसन का एंड इसमें मेरा
वीपीएस चल रहा है मेरी क्लाउड मशीन है
जिसमें यव ट यूज़ करता हूं बग बाउंट के
लिए अगर आपको भी बहुत फास्टर स्पीड चाहिए
बग बाउंटीज के लिए तो आप डिजिटल ओसन का
क्लाउड यूज कर सकते हो बहुत सस्ता बहुत ही
अफोर्डेबल होता है एंड जब फर्स्ट टाइम
हमारे लिंक से जो कि इस लाइव के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक मिल जाएगी आपको
उससे अगर साइन अप करते हो तो $200 का यहां
आपको क्रेडिट मिलता है एंड उस क्रेडिट को
आप 60 दिनों तक अगले दो महीने तक यूज
करोगे तो दो महीने तक बिंदास फ्री यूज करो
क्लाउड सर्विस फिर आदत हो जाएगी और
डिसोल्यूशन सस्ता है तो आपको मजा आने
लगेगा तो चलिए हम यहां पे मोबा एक्सटम
स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं
ठीक है और भाई मैं ये कोई प्रमोशन नहीं
करता हूं इनका इनके तरफ से कोई प्रमोशन का
मुझे नहीं मिला हुआ है अभी तक मिल जाता तो
अच्छी बात है यार मिल जाता तो लेकिन लेकिन
इन्होंने दिया नहीं है मुझे कोई प्रमोशन
वगैरह का मैं वैसे ही बोलता हूं रेफरल
क्रेडिट के लिए अभी दिखाऊं तुम्हें रेफरल
क्रेडिट मेरा कितना हुआ है देख लो देखो
देखो मैं रेफरल क्रेडिट के लिए करता हूं
लेकिन पता नहीं तुम लोग में से कितने लोग
$ स्पेंड करेंगे कि मुझे वो मिलेगा आई
डोंट नो बट ये
देखो देखो मेरे को कितने रेफरल से हो चुके
हैं कितने डॉलर हो चुके हैं $50
$750 ठीक है अगर इसको तुम करोगे डॉलर टू
आईआर तो यह देखो तुम 50 कितने होते हैं 1
लाख ₹
5360 लेकिन दुख की बात यह है दुख इस बात
का है कि यह पैसा मुझे कोई अकाउंट में
बैंक अकाउंट में नहीं मिलने वाला है ठीक
है तो यह इसलिए खुश मत होना ज्यादा यह
पैसा मेरे बैंक अकाउंट में नहीं मिलने
वाला
है हां पावर सेल भी यूज कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं पावर सेल भी यूज कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कोई दिक्कत नहीं ठीक है
यस श्यर सीएमडी यूज कर लो पावर सेल यूज कर
लो तुम यह भी यूज कर सकते हो सीएमडी
नॉर्मल वाली पावर सेल यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है तो यह इसमें से 25 डर जब
कोई स्पेंड करेगा यह जो इतने लोग है ना 70
लोग है 70 लोग रेफरल से करने वाले यह 2 ड
स्पेंड करेंगे तब मुझे मिलेगा 2
ड बलग अपलोड करो सर अरे करेंगे करेंगे भाई
करेंगे चलिए तो यहां
से आ जाते हैं यहां
पर
क
तो यह टारगेट है हमारा तो हम यहां से
लॉगिन हम यहां से लॉगइन कर लेते हैं
ओके ओके यह ऑफ है क्या आई थिंक ऑफ है यह
लेट्स रीलोड
इट ऑन तो किया था ना अरे ऑफ ही है यार अभी
तक हद
यार चलो ऑन कर लेता हूं
मैं
फेक क्रेडिट कार्ड यूज करके देख लो अगर हो
जाता है तो कर लो यार मुझे कहां कोई
दिक्कत है मुझे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है भाई आप
कैसे भी कर लो जेनन की तरह जेनुइन करो यार
आरसी टेक आपका बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद भाई आरसी
टेक भाई आशी टेक भी मस्त बंदा है तो 20 20
रप सुपर चैट करता रहता है मुझे एक यह और
एक डीजे डीजे तो हाई हाई प्रोफाइल केस है
लेकिन आरसी टेक का देखो देखो अरे भाई इसका
अभी नाम लिया और नाम लिया एंड
हाजिर धन्यवाद भाई डीजे मुझे लगता है डीजे
के तरफ से मुझे अभी तक आराम से न चज 4000
5000 मिल गए
होंगे चलो अब मुझे लगता है ना ट्राई हैक म
का और गिव अवे करना पड़ेगा यह जो आप लोग
सेंड करते हो सुपर चैट में तो मैं इसका
ट्राई हैक मी गिव अवे कर दिया करूंगा नीडी
लोगों के लिए जिनको नीड है ट्राई हैक मी
का उनके लिए कर दिया करूंगा ठीक है तो आई
थिंक वो ज्यादा बेटर होगा एक
ऑप्शन चलिए
तो नहीं पता मुझे अब यहां पर मैं यहां पर
कनेक्ट कर लेता हूं यहां पर अब आई थिंक हो
चुका
होगा
यस आई एम लगड इन इन टू माय मशीन गुड
इवनिंग
डीजे हां डीजे अमीर ही है भाई डीजे डीजे
बहुत अमीर है मुझे तो मुझे भी लगता है ऐसा
तो मुझे आईपी आईपी मिल चुकी है अब मैं
आईपी को एक बार हुज कर लेता हूं कि भैया
यह आईपी एक्चुअली बिलोंग किससे करती है
बिलोंग करती भी है कि नहीं बीएसएफ से
सो ठीक है अन डब् ओके ओके अमेजन एड्स आरपी
के ठीक
है
टेक्नोलॉजी डीजे तुम सच में स्टॉक मार्केट
में हो क्या स्टॉक मार्केटिंग करते हो ना
तुम ट्रेडिंग करते होगे तुम 110 पर तो ये
नेट रेंज यहां पे आ गया इसका ठीक है ये है
एंड दिस वन ओके चलो ओके एक बार इसको ही ऐज
ले लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं इसको टारगेट
ले लेंगे कोई टेंशन नहीं है तो मान लो ये
हमारा टारगेट है ये टारगेट हमने ले लिया
ठीक
है धन्यवाद धन्यवाद भाई धन्यवाद अब हम
टारगेट पे जैसे हमें एक टारगेट हमें कहीं
से आईपी उठानी है मैंने आपको क्या बताया
था हमें आईपी उठानी है तो हमें एक आईपी
यहां से सडन के रिजल्ट से मिल गई ठीक है
अब मान लो यहां पे बहुत सारे इनवैलिड
यूआरएल है है ना अब मान लो तो यहां पे
क्या है यहां पे हम फिल्टर करते हैं मोर
पे मोर प जाके फिल्टर करते हैं चलो मोर पे
एक बार चलते हैं फिल्टरिंग प चलते हैं
लेट्स गो टू द
फिल्टर फिल्टर प आने पे यहां पे गाइस अब
देखो यहां पे ना तुम्हें पोर्ट वाली
फिल्टर अभी लगी हुई है ये सारे पोर्ट्स
बेस आपको दिख जाएंगे कि कौन-कौन से पोर्ट
में क्या-क्या ओपन है कौन-कौन सा पोर्ट
ओपन है ठीक
है अरे फिर से इसने फिर से 400 कर दिए
डीजे भाई पहले एक बात बताइए मुझे सच सच
क्या आप ट्रेडिंग करते हैं क्या
और भाई तुम सही में बहुत पैसे वाले हो
भाई हमारी कंपनी में इन्वेस्ट करो यार
इन्वेस्ट करो रिटर्न अच्छा मिलेगा हमारा
स्टार्टअप बहुत जोरों सोरों से बढ़ने वाला
है आगे चलिए अ तो यहां पे अब आते हैं एंड
हम यहां पे आ जाते
हैं मुझे यहां पे आ जाना है एसटीडीपी
टाइटल पे एसटीडीपी टाइटल पे आ जाते हैं
ठीक है या एसटीडीपी टाइटल आप डाल सकते हैं
ठीक है अगर अ डालना है तो या फिर आप यू
कैन डू वन
थिंग चलो एसीडीपी टाइटल कर देते हैं यहां
पे एंड यहां पे सर्च पे क्लिक कर देते हैं
ठीक
है ट्रेडिंग सीख रहा हूं बट
तुम बट तुम ये तो बताओ भाई पैसे वाले तुम
हो यार बहुत पैसे वाले हो तुम पैसे वाले
भाई इतने लोग यहां लाइव देख रहे हैं अभी
डीजे ने प्रीवियस सेशन में 000 लगभग सुपर
चैट किए थे इस बार अभी इसने 800 कर दिए तो
तुम ही लोग बताओ यार यह पैसे वाला तो है
अब कौन है क्या करता है मुझे बिल्कुल नहीं
पता है तो अगर बताना चाहो तो बताओ ठीक है
तो यहां पे इनवैलिड यूआरएल है 4074 याद
रखिएगा
4074 तो इनको हम यहां से भैया रिमूव कर
देंगे पहली बात तो इस पर अगर तुम क्लिक
करोगे तो इसका एक फिल्टर बन जाएगा जैसे ही
इनवैलिड ल पर क्लिक करोगे ना देखो क्या
होगा यह इनवैलिड मिल गया अब इसको क्या करो
तुम माइनस कर दो माइनस माइनस मतलब हटा दो
अब सर्च
करो अब तुम्हें 1145 जो हैं वो यूआरएल मिल
गए हैं एंड दीज आर नॉट इनवैलिड अब ये
एक्सेस डिनाइड वाले मिल रहे हैं तो कोई
बात नहीं एक्सेस डिनाइड वाले चलेगा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है तो अब आप देख सकते हो कि
ये जो आईपीस हैं बीएसएफ से बिलोंग करते
हैं कोई और ऑर्गेनाइजेशन से बिलोंग करते
हैं किससे बिलोंग करते हैं एंड देन आपको
पता चल जाएगा जैसे ये 1view bsf.com है
ठीक है तो ये इन्हीं का लग रहा है मुझे तो
इन्हीं का लग रहा है बाकी हम देख लेंगे
वनव्यू
bsf.com
अ बीएसएफ यस यस यस ये इन्हीं का है यूआरएल
और इनका ही है ये ओके साइन इन टू यो
बीएसएफ एग्रीकल्चर सॉल्यूशन बहुत बढ़िया
सो वी कैन चेक फॉर अनदर अ वलने एबिलिटीज
वगैरह ऐसी जगहों पे वने बिलिटी कैसे फाइंड
करते हैं वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा टेंशन मत लो
आप लोगों को बग बाउटी के जर्नी में सब पता
चलता जाएगा तो चलिए यहां पे गाइस अब क्या
करते हैं हमें एक आईपी यहां भी मिली है
बीएसएफ वाली वन व्यू की चलिए इसको भी ओपन
कर लेते हैं इस आईपी पे हमारा एडवांस
रिस्क कर देते हैं यहां पे यहां पे ऐड आ
रहा है थोड़ा रुक जाता हूं मैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ऑन दिस आईपी ओके इस आईपी
पे यही वाला है हमारा अ एक कुछ साइन इन
पोर्टल है यहां पे आईपी पे तो हम इस आईपी
को क्या करते हैं पकड़ सकते हैं तो यह
आईपी कौन सी है भैया यह वाली आईपी है चलो
आईपी को अरे रे रे रे आईपी वहां से भी भी
कॉपी कर सकते हैं लेकिन यहां से भी कॉपी
कर लिया कोई बात नहीं तो हम यहां पे एक
टारगेट हमें मिल चुकी है एंड वी हैव द
टारगेट यह
वाला बहुत बढ़िया यह वाला एक टारगेट हो
गया हमारे पास चलिए और भी टारगेट निकालते
हैं टारगेट निकालना हमारा बहुत टारगेट
निकालना बहुत जरूरी है ठीक है डीजे बताओ
यार थोड़ा हिंट तो दो क्या करते हो हिंट
तो दे दोगे यार कम से कम नहीं बतानी पूरी
बात तो ठीक है एक टारगेट हमारा ये वाला हम
ले सकते हैं 50 यह हालाकि इससे रिलेटेड
शायद मे बी ना हो बट ठीक है एक टारगेट यह
ले लेते हैं पहला टारगेट हम पहले देखेंगे
देन वीी कैन सी हियर वेब सर्वर यह कौन सा
है बीएसएफ डिजिटल सॉल्यूशन ठीक है यह क्या
है वेब सर्वर में क्या है भैया लेट्स
सी चैट में सभी लोग रुको जरा दिमाग मत ल
क्या बात
है चलिए य देख लेते
हैं एनीवे बहुत
अ सर अगर आप 6 महीने क्लास लोगे तो डीजे
आपको लखपति बना देगा हां यह बात भी हो
सकता है मे बी पॉसिबल है सही है भाई नहीं
मैं डीजे अभी जो डीजे ने किया है जो भी अ
ये सुपर चैट कर रहा है मैंने सोचा है कुछ
अ कि कुछ गिव अवेज वगैरह करता रहूंगा मैं
नीडी लोगों के
लिए
चलिए यहां पे अब हमें एक वेब सवा का मिला
है अभी नॉट फाउंड नॉट कनेक्शन नॉट ऐसा आ
रहा है तो ठीक है एक बार देख लेते हैं
यहां पे व्हाई आई एम हियर ये क्या है अ
दिस इज अ चलो दो आईपी हमें मिल चुके हैं
दो आईपी को हम देख लेते हैं पहले वाली
पहली आईपी प अब हम यहां पे आ जाते हैं
सिंपल सा फंडा है हम यहां पे सबसे पहले
हमें जो आईपी मिली है जैसे हमें पहली आईपी
मिली ठीक है ये वाली आईपी हमें मिली पहली
वाली तो हम पहले इस पे हु इज करके आईपी की
डिटेल्स निकाल लेते हैं ठीक है जैसे हमने
अभी निकाला आईपी की डिटेल्स तो आईपी की
डिटेल्स पता चल जाएगी डब् इंस्टेंस का है
ये ओबवियसली है तो कोई कोई दिक्कत नहीं
कनेक्टेड टू दैट बीएसएफ है तो अब हम यहां
पे डायरेक्ट आईपी हमें नहीं मिल पा रही है
ट की आईपी मिल पा रही है तो हम बहुत
ज्यादा कुछ इसपे नहीं कर पाएंगे हमें
फाइंड करना है ऐसा कोई आईपी जो डायरेक्टली
कंपनी से लिंक्ड हो समझ में आ रहा है जो
कंपनी से लिंक कर रही हो उसकी आईपी हमें
फाइंड करनी है तो ज्यादा बेटर आपके लिए
होगा जैसे एक ये आईपी है लेट्स हु इज
इट
ओके दिस इ आल्सो अनन रिलेटेड
आईपी लेट्स क्लोज इट लेट्स चेक दिस
आईपी यह आईपी को देख लेते हैं हु इज कंपनी
से रिलेटेड आईपी डायरेक्टली हो तो ज्यादा
बेटर है कि सर्विस प्रोवाइडर से हो तो सही
नहीं हां यह आईपी है डीजे सॉरी बीएसएफ की
अभी देखो यह आईपी जो हमें मिली है गाइस
दिस
आईपी यो
स्टूडेंट मेरा स्टूडेंट कौन है भाई
यार अरे भाई मेरा स्टूडेंट कौन है मैं
समझा नहीं यार तुम मतलब
डीजे पता नहीं यार तुमने तो लकी से क्लास
ली थी ना शायद जहां तक तुमने बताया था
शायद तो मेरे स्टूडेंट कैसे हो गए शायद
तुमने लकी से किया था लकी हमारा टीम मेट
है लेकिन तुमने शायद लकी से लिया था शायद
तो चलिए यहां पे
अब यह जो आईपी मिली है भैया हमें 141
63224 यह आईपी पर हम चलते हैं यह आईपी कौन
सी थी भैया चलिए देख लेते हैं शान पे यह
मस्त आईपी है 141 63224 यह आईपी रिलेटेड
है डायरेक्ट बीएसएफ से यह बहुत अच्छी बात
है इसका हम यूज कर सकते हैं वेब सर्वर का
वेब सर्वर यहां पर दिखा रहा है बट यहां पर
कुछ है
क्या कैन वी ओपन समथिंग लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी थैंक यू थैंक यू डीजे
ठीक है एक बोल रहा है कितना देगा रे अरे
भाई
साहब चलिए यहां पे अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे
हम कर देते हैं अब एन मैप का पहले एक छोटा
सा सिंपल सा कमांड चलाएंगे अरे आरसी टेक
भी आरसी टेक ने वो लगा लिया है
वो कंपटीशन एन मैप करेंगे यहां पे सिंपल
सा पहले और एन मैप के बाद यहां पर हम
सिंपल एक क्या करेंगे एक सर्विस डिटेक्शन
करेंगे हाइन एसवी से सर्विस डिटेक्शन
करेंगे इसमें हम यहां पर कुछ और चीजें यूज
कर सकते हैं हाइन t4 यूज कर सकते हैं या
t3 रहने देते हैं कोई बात नहीं एंड नॉर्मल
सा एक सर्विस रेक्शन कर लेते हैं पहले ठीक
है अरे कोई बात नहीं आरटेक इतना ही आप
बहुत कर रहे हो आपको कंपटीशन नहीं करना
है प्लीज डोंट
कंपीट आप इतना कर रहे हो वही बहुत है
भाई
चलिए यहां से 99 पर हो चुका है लेट्स सी इ
वी आर गेटिंग समथिंग कुछ मिलता है कि नहीं
मिलता है इधर ध्यान दीजिए आप लोग अरे भाई
तुम लोग इधर ध्यान दो
यार टर्मिनल कौन सा यह मोबा एक्सटम मोबा
एक्सटम है भैया मोबा एक्सम बस आरटेक रहने
दो मोबा
एक्सटम यह वाली मैं यूज कर रहा हूं फ्री
है आपका होम एडिशन आप यूज कर कर सकते हैं
मोबा
एक्टम चलिए तो यहां पे आई थिंक हो चुकी है
स्टिल स्कैनिंग हो रही है यहां पे लेट्स
सी हां लेट्स
सी हां बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं बिल्कुल
अ लेट्स सी हाउ मच परसेंटेज इट हैज डन 9
2.86 ठीक है यह चल रहा है इसका इसमें हम
t4 यूज कर लेते तो थोड़ा फास्ट हो जाता है
बट चलो यहां पे अब यहां पे एक बढ़िया सा
यूज करते हैं यहां पे सेम कमांड यहां पे
हम यूज करते हैं हाइन एसवी ही लगाते हैं
ठीक है हम हाइन एसवी लगाते हैं अब यहां पे
हम हाइन t4 थोड़ा फास्ट करते हैं t4 यहां
पे यूज कर लेते हैं ठीक है स्पीड के लिए
इतना आप समझ लीजिए हाइन ए लगा देंगे अब न
ए क्या करता है हान ए मल्टीपल एन मैप के
फिल्टर्स को चलाता है ठीक है मल्टीपल एन
मैप की क्वेरीज को चलाता है जिसमें कुछ
कुछ जैसे सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन इसमें
इंक्लूड है आपका ठीक है ना या ट्रेस रूट
जो है वो भी इंक्लूड है इसमें आप ए मैप की
चीटशीट देख लीजिएगा आपको मिल जाएगा वैसे
देख लीजिए यहां पे ए मैप चीटशीट ठीक है
यहां पे आ जाइए यहां पे हान ए अग्रेसिव
स्कैन करता है जिसमें मल्टीपल कुछ क्वेरीज
है वो पास आउट करता है ठीक है जैसे कि
जैसे कि जैसे कि लेट्स सी लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी ये वाली तो ओस डिटेक्शन हो
गया वर्जन डिटेक्शन हो गई स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैनिंग हो गई और ट्रे सूट सारे एक साथ
चला देता है तो यह आप कर सकते हैं इसके
बाद आप यहां पे मिनिमम रेट लगा सकते हैं
मिनिमम रेट जैसे यह यहां पे देखिए चीटशीट
में सब कुछ हो मिलेगा अगर आप ध्यान से
कीजिएगा
तो वयर इट इज़ वयर इट इज यह रहा मिनिमम
रेट यह रहा मिन रेट तो मिनिमम रेट क्या
करेगा सेंड पैकेट्स नो स्लोअर देन इतने
इससे स्लो आपको पैकेट नहीं भेजना है तो
हाइफ मिन हाइन रेट यह वाला आप लगा सकते हो
ठीक है तो हम यहां पे हाइन मिन हाइन रेट
लगा देते हैं एंड इसको कर देते हैं 1000
एंड यहां पे एक मैक्स ट्राई का भी एक शीट
एक मैक्स ट्राई भी होगा शायद मैक्स रि
ट्राइज हां मैक्स रि ट्राइज यह भी लगा
देते हैं तो यहां पे डिफॉल्ट कुछ है क्या
इसका ओके मैक्स ट्राइज थ लगा देते हैं
थ्री ही कर देते हैं तो हान मैक्स अ री
ट्राइज थ मैक्सिमम
रिट्राईंग देखते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग एन मैप क्या हमें सामने रिजल्ट
देता है लेट्स सी लेट्स वेट अरे आरसी टेक
भाई धन्यवाद भाई रहने दो
यार सर पिज्जा पार्टी करेंगे अब बट वो जो
सुपर चैट है वो तुरंत नहीं आती है अकाउंट
में यार वो एक महीने बाद मिलता
है फायर वल ब्लॉक करने का भी मैं अभी
बताता
हूं आई विल लेट यू
नो
नहीं नहीं भाई हैकिंग छोड़ के ट्रेडिंग मत
करो यार ऐसे इन्फ्लुएंस मत हुआ करो ऐसे
इन्फ्लुएंस मत हुआ
करो आज 80 प्लस स्टूडेंट्स ऐसा कैसे य
डीजे के सुपर चैट को देखने तो नहीं आ रहे
भाई तुम
लोग सर जेएस फाइल में ग मैप की एपीआई मिली
है मुझे वने बिलिटी कंसीडर होगी क्या अरे
नहीं भाई वो मतलब अगर आप कुछ इंपैक्ट दिखा
सकते हो उस एपीआई से कुछ आप मालिश अस
एक्सेस ले सकते हो सिंपली अनऑथेंटिकेटेड
कोई एक्सेस मिल जाता है किसी कोई
प्रिविलेज मिल जाती है कुछ कर पा रहे हो
तभी वो एक्सेप्ट एक्सेप्ट होगा सिर्फ
एपीआई की मिल जाने से वो एक्सेप्ट नहीं
होता है आज के टाइम में बग बाउंट जो
प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं वो आपके इंपैक्ट को
देखते हैं इंपैक्ट है तो ही एक्सेप्ट
करेंगे अदर वाइज नहीं अगर वो है भी तो भी
नहीं एक्सेप्ट करेंगे तो इंपैक्ट दिखाओ ना
अगर इंपैक्ट हो रहा है तो ठीक
है
ओके 36 पर हुआ यहां
पे इसमें थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा बट वर्थ
होगा तो वी कैन वेट फॉर दैट ठीक
है देख लेते
हैं बताओ भाई डीजे यार कौन हो यार थोड़ा
तो हिंट दो यार हिंट में ए स्टूडेंट बोल
दिया लेकिन कौन स्टूडेंट हो यार कुछ पता
तो कुछ ट हिंट तो मिला नहीं मुझे
लेट्स
सी देखो यहां पे वन अंडरगोइंग ट्रेस रूट
पैरेलल डीएनएस रेजोल्यूशन ऑफ 11 होस्ट यह
सब कुछ कर रहा है मतलब आपको बस थोड़ा वेट
करना है रिजल्ट का वेट करना
है
सॉरी आज लाइव आ गई अटेंड नहीं कर पाऊंगी
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं तानिया आप
रिकॉर्डिंग देख लीजिएगा इट्स 8.82 पर वी
हैव टू
वेट अरे तुम लोग यह चैट में क्या 1000
2000 यह क्या कर रहे हो
भाई भाई तुम लोग 77 लोग हो सिर्फ 66
लाइक्स है मतलब क्या है यह क्या है मतलब
यार एक वो डीजे को देखो सुपर चैट सुपर चैट
करता है मतलब उसका सपोर्ट अलग ही लेवल का
है और तुम लोग लाइक तक नहीं कर पा रहे हो
भाई उसमें तो पैसे भी नहीं देने यार वो तो
काम कर दो कम से
कम ना भाई डीजे इतने पैसे नहीं करने हैं
इससे अच्छा तो इन्वेस्ट ही कर दो यार तुम
हमारी कंपनी में व ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा
इन्वेस्टमेंट करो रिटर्न भी
मिलेगा की बहुत जरूरत है भाई हमें अभी
तो अ लाइक कर दिया लगता है ओहो लाइक मार
दिया सबने चलो बहुत बढ़िया धन्यवाद भाई
इतना सुनते हो तुम लोग ये बहुत बड़ी बात
है अच्छा तुम लोगों को क्या हो जाता है
मतलब मतलब एक बार कभी 20 40 50 लोग आते हो
एक बार सीधा 7080 आ जाते हो क्या दिक्कत
क्या है मतलब क्या सोचते क्या हो थोड़ा और
बचा हुआ है थोड़ा और वेट
कीजिए ओके ओके
धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद लेट्स हट ऑन
डीजे अरे क्या हुआ भाई बताओ
यार क्या हुआ बेनी एडिट क्या पूछा आपने
कुछ मैसेज तो ऊपर है नहीं यार एक बार फिर
से मैसेज कर लो ना क्या दिक्कत है थोड़ा
और बचा लेट्स वेट य हमारा टारगेट को हमने
किया है
साक टैंक लते हैं अरे साक टैंक में यार
ऐसे नहीं जाते यार वह लोग साक टैंक की
कहानी डार्क है व जितना अच्छा दिखता है
सामने आप लोगों को एक्चुअली होता नहीं है
वैसा प्रोसेस डिफरेंट एवरीथिंग इज द गेम
ऑफ
टीआरपी तो व टीआरपी वाली गेम है वहां
पर कितना परसेंट इक्विटी मिलेगा एक लाख
में एक लाख की इन्वेस्टमेंट थोड़ी ना
चाहिए यार एक लाख की इन्वेस्टमेंट तो मैं
कर ही लूंगा ना एक लाख की इन्वेस्टमेंट
नहीं चाहिए एटलीस्ट आप लोग इन्वेस्टमेंट
का मतलब होता है एटलीस्ट 10 लाख का
इन्वेस्टमेंट छोटी सी इन्वेस्टमेंट की अगर
मैं बात करूं स्टार्टअप में तो 10 लाख
इन्वेस्ट करने का फिर इक्विटी की बात कर
सकते
हैं
सर बाउंटीज हम भी सुपर चैट करेंगे बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया ग्रेट चलो इतना सोच
रहे हो बहुत अच्छी बात है आई विश कि आपको
बाउंटीज करवा के
आ लेकिन तुम लोग तुम लोग डीजे वाली
कंपटीशन में नहीं आ पाओगे उसका उसका मुझे
अभी पता नहीं चल पा रहा है लेकिन मैं उसका
भी पता देखता हूं मैं डीजे कांटेक्ट करो
यार पहले तुम तो हो कौन यार मुझे कांटेक्ट
कर लो अगर स्टूडेंट हो तो तुम मेरे
कांटेक्ट में हो ग 100% तो वो कांटेक्ट
करो यार तो ये अलग-अलग तरह के स्क्रिप्ट्स
को स्क्रिप्ट्स की स्कैनिंग रनिंग कर रहा
है स्क्रिप्ट्स रन कर रहा है एंड
दैट्ची है एंड देन आपको रिजल्ट देगा तो
इसमें थोड़ा सा टाइम लग जाएगा ओके तो हम
इसको क्या करते हैं इसको रन करने देते हैं
अभी फिलहाल के लिए हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं कुछ और भी चीज जो है वो करते हैं ठीक
है
तो लेट इट
रन इसको हम रन होने देते हैं ऐसे ही कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है इसको रन होने देते हैं अब
क्या करते हैं यहां
पर ओके लेट्स ओपन
यर चलिए नाउ आई एम गोइंग टू कॉपी इट
एंड लेट्स ओपन द कमांड कमांड
प्रोमट सीएस एंड एस रूट
रेट एंड देन
लेट्स एंटर लेट्स लॉग इन एंड वी आर लॉग इन
ठीक है तो हमने यहां पे एक और लॉगइन यहां
प कर लिया फिलहाल के लिए इसको जो है वो जो
है चल रहा है अपना चलने दो रिजल्ट को हम
देखेंगे क्या होता है तो हमें यहां पे
जैसे क्या मिला हमें शोडाउन से क्या मिला
है हमें भैया यहां से हमें आईपी एक मिल
जाई है ये आईपी बेसिकली बिलोंग करता है
बीएसएफ से क्योंकि हमने हु इज करके देख
लिया था वैसे ही आप अलग-अलग जो आईपीस हैं
उनको देख सकते हैं कौन सा बिलोंग करता है
एक्चुअल उस पर्टिकुलर कंपनी से और कौन सा
किसी और सर्विस से तो सडन के लिस्ट में
आपको कई बार ऐसे भी मिल जाएंगे आईपी जो उस
पर्टिकुलर कंपनी का है ही नहीं अब वहां पे
कोई बग रिपोर्ट कर दोगे तुम बीएसएफ में
जाके यहां पे ओबवियसली वो तुमको बाउंट
नहीं देंगे वो बोलेंगे हमारा ये कोई
सिस्टम ही नहीं है हमारा कोई आर्किटेक्चर
ही नहीं है हमारा कोई नेटवर्क ही नहीं है
फिर हम कहां से आपको बाउंडी देंगे सिंपल
सी चीज है तो जैसे अब ये है बीएसएफ
स्टायरो सेम य क्या है भाई यह भी
इंटरेस्टिंग थोड़ा लग रहा है ऐसी आईपीस पर
तुम डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग भी कर सकते
हो भाई याद रखना सो दिस इज समथिंग
ओके सम लॉगिन सिस्टम ग्रेट एफ लॉगइन
फेडरेशन क्यू
ओके ठीक है ठीक है व्ट टाइप ऑफ लॉगिन इट इ
आरस
टोकन एंड ऑथेंटिकेटर प ओके तो यह दोनों
में से कोई सा भी हम नहीं कर पाए तो यूजर
नेम पासवर्ड एंटर कोड फ्रॉम डिवाइस ओके सो
बट वी कैन वी कैन जस्ट ब्रूट फोर्स इट
मतलब सॉरी हम यहां पे ब्रूटोस में बोल रहा
हूं हम यहां पर स्कैनिंग कर सकते एक बार
ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है यहां पे ट्राई आउट मारने में कुछ नहीं
जाता है यहां प पहले तो हम हुज कर लेते
हैं एंड यहां पर आईपी डाल देते हैं एंटर
कर देते हैं एंड इट्स बिलोंग टू पर्सन दे
दिव्या कमारा एड्रेस वन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वे
रेडमंड ठीक है एंड दिस रिलेटेड टू बीएसएफ
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट लिमिटेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेम
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट लिमिटेड ओके
ग्रेट ठीक है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट से रिलेटेड भी
है तो भी हम इसपे स्कैन तो मार ही सकते
हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है स्कैन मारने में
क्या जाता है हमारा है ना चलो वो भी
रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं ना कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है तो हम यहां पे एम h एवी यहां सिंपल सा
फॉर्मेट दे देते हैं स्कैनिंग कर लेते हैं
यहां पे या तो आप सिंपल पोर्ट स्कैनिंग भी
पहले कर सकते हो पहले अगर आपको चाहिए कि
सिर्फ पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते हैं नॉर्मली कि
कौन सा पोर्ट क्या ओपन है क्या है क्लोज
है वो भी आप कर सकते हो सिंपल सा एंड मैप
का चीटशीट यूज कर लो एंड यू कैन जस्ट यूज
इट तो हम क्या कर लेते हैं एंड मैप कर
लेते हैं एंड यहां पे हम टारगेट को मेंशन
कर देते हैं जो हमारा टारगेट है एंड यहां
पे हम एस एस ए ठीक है एस एन किस लिए होता
है याद है सबको ना भाई देख लो यहां पे एस
एन एस एन एस एन कहां गया कहां गया कहां
गया एस एन डिसेबल पोर्ट स्कैनिंग पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग हम डिसेबल कर देंगे अभी फिलहाल
के लिए अ इसके लिए अगर एस ए को यूज कर रहे
हो तो अगर सिर्फ अगर एंटर करते हो तो ये
सिंपली होस्ट अप दिखा देगा अब हम यहां पे
सिफ पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करना है तो हान पीए
लगा सकते हो या फिर सिंपली यह हाफ पीएन आप
मत भी लगाओ कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ईन पीए
वैसे क्या होता है कि डिसेबल होस्ट
डिस्कवरी तो चलो कोई बात हम नहीं लगाते
हैं अब हम नॉर्मल सा पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करते
हैं नॉर्मल सा पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के लिए क्या
करोगे सारे पोर्ट्स को अगर तुम्हें स्कैन
करना है तो हाइन प प लगा दोगे पी हाइन प
और हाइन अगर तुम ऐसे लगा देते हो हाइन प
और हाइन तो जितने भी पोर्ट्स हैं वो सब के
सब स्कैन करेगा तो पहले तो हम यहां पे हाई
अ क्या थी यार 164 थी ना h t 4 लगा देते
हैं थोड़ा सा फास्ट कर देते हैं एंड यहां
पे सारे पोर्ट्स को तो हम स्कैन नहीं
करेंगे बट वी विल बी स्कैनिंग सम अ
पोर्ट्स इनिशियल पोर्ट इन रेंज मेक्स द
स्कैन अ स्टार्ट एट पोर्ट नं वन तो ठीक है
हान p से हाफ p से 1023 तक लगा देते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है 1023 पोर्ट्स
जो हैं स्टार्टिंग के उनको यूज कर लेते
हैं बस एंड यहां पे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग का कोई
अगर आपको स्पेसिफिक यूज करना है अ काइंड
ऑफ स्कैनिंग टेक्निक्स यूज करनी है तो आप
यूज कर सकते हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट आपका हान एसस
सिन स्कैन पोर्ट होता है तो आप या तो यह
बाय डिफॉल्ट रहने दीजिए या तो आप सिंपली
लगा दीजिए कोई और भी और एंटर कर दीजिए और
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग देखते हैं क्या
होता है व्हाट रिजल्ट्स वी आर
गेटिंग
क्या हुआ
भाई चलिए यहां पर हमें रिजल्ट आ चुका है
एंड रिजल्ट में हमें कुछ खास यहां मिला
नहीं है ठीक है वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग
एनीथिंग कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास हमें नहीं मिला
है हम थोड़ा सा चेंजेज वगर कर सकते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं अरे हमने यहां पर कमांड
क्या डाला था
भाई दिस वन ना हां ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है तो हम यहां पर थोड़ा सा चेंजेज क्या कर
सकते हैं लाइक वी कैन यूज सम अदर
टेक्निक्स आल्सो अगर आपको कुछ अदर टेक्निक
यूज करनी है तो आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो
लाइक अगर यूडीपी स्कैन करनी है या एसी के
करना है या विंडो पोर्ट स्कैन करनी है तो
एडब ए ए भी लगा सकते हो तो हम सेम कमांड
में न s डल पहले लगा देते हैं विंडो वाली
देखते
हैं क्या है रिजल्ट इधर देखिए आप लोग
प्लीज कितने लोग हैं बहुत
बढ़िया लेट्स सी व्हाट आर वी गेटिंग सम
डिफरेंट रिजल्ट्स और
क्या 0 का सुपर चैट डीजे के तरफ से
धन्यवाद
डीजे
भाई डीजे थोड़ा हिंट भी दे दिया करो यार
जब सुपर चैट करो तो उसी के अंदर में कि
क्या है ये कौन मतलब थोड़ा सा कुछ तो दो
चलो यहां पे आ चुके हैं यहां पे एंड वी आर
वेटिंग फॉर द रिजल्ट्स लाट इफ वी गेटिंग
समथिंग
समथिंग एस डब्
पडल कुछ यहां पे आया
क्या 44 पर 46 पर इसका हम देख लेते हैं
क्या रिजल्ट है अभी तो इसकी स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैनिंग चल रही है बहुत सारे स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैनिंग करते हैं हान a पे थोड़ा टाइम
आपको लग जाता है गाइस थोड़ा वेट करना 14
मिनट 22 सेकंड बहुत टाम 14 मिनट के आसपास
लगेंगे य लगभग
ऑलमोस्ट
ओ आई होप डेनिक्स को सब लोग सपोर्ट करें
आई विश कि सभी लोग सपोर्ट करें हमारे
डेनिक्स को क्योंकि हम कुछ बुरा तो नहीं
कर रहे किसी का इस बार किसी भी एंगल से सो
होप
सो चलो इसमें तो थ टाइम लगेगा इसका क्या
हाल है भाई 73 हो गया है लेट्स
वेट इसको हम हान a के जगह पे वैसे अगर हम
न a के जगह पे हमने यह जो न a लगा दिया है
इसकी वजह से थोड़ा सा खराब हो रहा है बहुत
ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा चीजें आ जा रही है
यहां पे तो i s भी ओनली कर देते हैं एंड
लेट्स सी खाली सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन कर
लेते हैं क्या आ रहा है यह होस्ट सीम्स
डाउन
हैं यह क्या दिक्कत है
यार अभी होस्ट सीम्स डाउन हाउ इट इज
पॉसिबल अरे
भैया होस्ट डाउन था क्या
ये पिंग कर लेते हैं ना क्या दिक्कत है
अच्छा ठीक है होस्ट का इशू ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं है यहां पे ये हो रहा
है यहां पे एंड यहां पर हमनी सर्विस यहां
पर हमने पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करी थी कुछ नहीं
मिला था यहां पे वापस से हमने ये चलाया
हमने एड स्कैन एंड वी डिन गेट एनीथिंग ऑल
द व इग्नोर स्टेट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं हम
सेम आईपी को यहां पे ले सकते हैं 15 यह
वाली आईपी थी ना
हमारी
लेट्स लेट्स टेक दिस आईपी 64 वाली एंड
प्रीवियस हमारी कमांड जो थी इसके अंदर बस
हम आईपी की रिप्लेसमेंट कर देते हैं लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग
चलिए
या करेक्ट एकदम सही बात
है यस पी एन लगा सकते हैं बट आई डोंट थिंक
सो वी आर आई डोंट थिंक वी विल गेट द
रिजल्ट्स मुझे नहीं लगता है बट यहां पर
हमें रिजल्ट मिला है एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज हैपनिंग ये तो फिंगर प्रिंटिंग हो गई
पोर्ट नंबर 80 एंड 443 ही ओपन है और तो
कुछ यहां पे नहीं मिला हमें नथिंग राइट तो
चलिए एक बार लेट्स सी सेम कमांड जैसा आपने
बोला बट यहां पे होस्ट डाउन है ना यार तो
आई डोंट थिंक की इट विल वर्क लेट्स सी
देखते हैं देखा ना कुछ नहीं है यहां पे
मैंने बोला था यहां पे नथिंग इज यर हमने
यूज किया एंड
नथिंग कुछ हमें मिला नहीं यहां पे कुछ ऐसा
कुछ खास हमें नहीं
मिला राइट ट्स वई तो यह हमने ये तो हमने
किया यह
तो यह तो हमने किया यह तो हमने नॉर्मल
स्कैनिंग मतलब हमने मैप से स्कैनिंग की
अलग-अलग तरीके से हमने आईपी फाइंड किया
आईपी फाइंड करने की कोशिश की जैसे अलग-अलग
अब जैसे ये एक आईपी है ये कोई चाइनीज आईपी
लग रही है मुझे इनका कुछ है ग्लोबल है तो
ओबवियसली कहीं का भी हो सकता है 4713 55
ऐसे करके 503 सर्विस अनअवेलेबल यह आ रहा
है अब इसको हम पिंग करके एक बार देख सकते
हैं पहले तो यार पिंग ही कर लो लाइक इट इज
पिंग और
नॉट सो या इट्स
पििन अवेलेबल है सर्वर एरर आ रही है बट
यहां प पिंग हम कर पा रहे हैं तो ओबवियसली
वी कैन डू समथिंग ऑन इट राइट तो हम सेम
कमांड में क्या करते हैं वी आर
जस्ट रिप्लेसिंग दिस वन एंड स वर्जन
डिटेक्शन कर लेते हैं एंड मिनिमम रेट 1000
ठीक है देख लेते
हैं होस्ट डिस्कवरी को हमने डिसेबल कर
दिया है हान पीएन लगा के ओबवियसली पहले ही
होस्ट डिस्कवरी हमने बंद कर दिया है ठीक
है अरे कोई बात नहीं
हटाओ जाने दो अभी क्या करते हैं हम अपनी
बात करते हैं ठीक है हम अपनी बात करते हैं
लेट्स लेट्स लेट्स लीव द अदर थिंग्स अदर
जो नेम्स है ओके प्लीज अपनी बात करते हैं
अपना करते हैं ना अपना लर्निंग करते हैं
किसी को भी कुछ भी बोलते नहीं है अपना
मस्त लर्निंग करते हैं मस्त सीखते हैं
मस्त आगे बढ़ते हैं क्या दिक्कत है है ना
ट्स इट चलिए हमें यहां रिजल्ट मिला है एंड
इज इट इज देयर
समथिंग
ए पोर्ट है 443 एंड नथिंग मच कुछ खास यहां
पे हमें मिला नहीं है सो या नथिंग वी गॉट
हियर कुछ खास हमें मिला नहीं है राइट अब
हम इस पे अब आगे चलके हम और भी चीजें करने
वाले हैं अब हम जो है करने वाले हैं
स्टार्ट जो हम समझने वाले हैं सीखने वाले
हैं वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट एंड वी आर
गोइंग टू लर्न ए मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन
ठीक है हम क्या करने वाले हैं एनएससी को
पढ़ने वाले हैं ए मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग
एंजन अब यह क्या है यह जो है ना
यह एक तरह का एक तरह का स्क्रिप्ट है एक
तरह का स्क्रिप्ट है ठीक है जो कि एक
लैंग्वेज में लिखी गई है जिसे कि लुआ
स्क्रिप्ट बोलते हैं लुआ लैंग्वेज बोलते
हैं अगर आपको मैं यहां पे
दिखाऊं लेट्स
सी एनएससी एन मैप तो यहां पर जब आप चलेंगे
ए मैप के ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट प तो यहां पर आप
देखेंगे यहां पे तो इसके बारे में आपको
सारी डिटेल्स यहां पे मिल जाएंगी ए मैप के
अ ए मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन के बारे में
एंड कंट्रोल एफ एल यू ए और यहां पे आपको
दिख जाएगा इज वन ऑफ द एमस मोस्ट पावरफुल
एंड फ्लेक्सिबल फीचर्स इट अलाउ यूजर्स टू
राइट सिंपल स्क्रिप्ट्स यूजिंग द लुआ
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेजेस टू ऑटोमेट अ वाइड
वैरायटी ऑफ नेटवर्किंग टास्क्स तो आप
बेसिकली एम स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन से ऑटोमेशन
कर सकते हो अपनी खुद की स्क्रिप्ट्स भी
बना सकते हो लुआ प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
अगर आपको आती है तो अदर वाइज इसके ऑलरेडी
600 के 600 से भी ज्यादा है मेरे ख्याल से
से स्क्रिप्ट्स अवेलेबल है आप उनको यूज कर
सकते हो आप उन स्क्रिप्ट्स को चला के एंड
आप अपना ऑटोमेशन एंड मैप स्कैनिंग वगैरह
यह सारी चीजें कर सकते हो ठीक है अब इसको
कैसे करना है टारगेट के लिए कैसे क्या
चीजें करनी है वो मैं अभी आपको बताता हूं
ठीक है चलिए
देखिए
सॉरी
डिस्कॉर्डेंट इंजन यह कहां से आएगा तो
इसका मैं पहले आपको लोकेशन दिखा देता हूं
जब आप एम को इंस्टॉल करोगे तो यूजुअली एम
स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन कहां होता है सीडी के
अंदर सीडी आप में उस लोकेशन पे चलते हैं
यूएसआर के अंदर में शेयर के अंदर में ए
मैप के अंदर में यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट्स
मिलेगा इसके अंदर में ये स्क्रिप्ट्स पाए
जाते हैं इसके अंदर चलते हैं एलएस करते
हैं एलएस
करेंगे तो आपको सारी जो स्क्रिप्ट है व
मिल जाएंगी सारी स्क्रिप्ट्स की जो
एक्सटेंशन होंगी व डॉट एनए होंगी डॉट
एनएस तो यह सारी आपको स्क्रिप्ट मिल
जाएंगे इसी तरीके से अगर आपको लाइक लोकेट
करना है आप लोकेट भी कर सकते हैं डॉट
एनएससी करेंगे तो आपको एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट
जितने हैं वो सारे यहां पे देखने को मिल
जाएंगे एंड इसकी लोकेशन यूएसआर शेयर एंड
मैप स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड ये मिल जाएंगी अब मान
लो मेरे पास एक टारगेट है ठीक है मान लो
मेरे पास एक टारगेट आईपी है मान लो उसे
ऐसे टारगेट यूज करने वाला हूं अब मैं किसी
पर्टिकुलर स्क्रिप्ट को यूज करने वाला हूं
तो आप ए मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन के अंदर के
अलग-अलग स्क्रिप्ट्स को बेसिकली यूज कर
सकते हैं ठीक है जैसे कि यहां पे आप चलिए
इनके ऑफिशियल गाइड पे ही चलते हैं यहां पे
डायरेक्टली ए मैप
एनएससी लेट्स ओपन यहां हटा देते हैं इसको
इसको रहने दे इसको हटा देते हैं चलो इसको
भी रहने देते हैं तो यहां पे आ चुके हैं
हम एम स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन पे यहां पे तो इस
तरीके से आप यूज कर सकते हैं एनम
स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन को बेसिकली इसको यूज
करने का ए मैप के चीट शीट में ऑलरेडी आपका
दिया हुआ है अगर आप चीट शीट में जाएंगे
यहां पे तो नीचे के नीचे की तरफ थोड़ा सा
आएंगे थोड़ा सा नीचे तो ए मैप स्क्रिप्ट
का यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा हान एसी स्विच
यूज कीजिएगा तो डिफॉल्ट यहां पे
स्क्रिप्टिंग जो डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट है जो
कुछ टास्क आपकी परफॉर्म करती है वो आपकी
चल जाती है ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे अ
बेसिकली ये एनएसए डिफॉल्ट एनएसए
स्क्रिप्ट्स कंसीडर यूज फॉर डिस्कवरी एंड
सेफ ठीक है यहां पे कुछ डिफॉल्ट
स्क्रिप्ट्स है उसको उसको चलाएगी तो आप
हाइन स्क्रिप्ट डिफॉल्ट भी लिख सकते हैं
ऐसे भी एंड कोई स्क्रिप्ट आपको डालना है
तो हाइन स्क्रिप्ट इ इक्वल टू आप
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम दे देंगे तो भी आपका चल
जाएगा या कोई पर्टिकुलर प्रोटोकॉल से
रिलेटेड स्क्रिप्ट है तो आप इस तरीके से
लिख सकते हैं इस तरीके से सारी चीजें कर
सकते हैं ठीक है ना अब मान लो मुझे मैं
यहां पे आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां पे जैसे
इनके हेल्प फाइल यहां प ऑफिशियल पेज पे
आइएगा तो आपको यहां सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी
अब यहां पे जैसे ही इन्होंने दिया हुआ है
न स्क्रिप्ट डीब यहां पे दिया हुआ है एम
नफन स्क्रिप्ट एंड ये वाइल्ड कार्ड में
एचटीटीपी दिया हुआ है इसका मतलब क्या हुआ
कि लोडस ऑल स्क्रिप्ट्स हुज ने स्टार्ट
विथ एचटीटीपी सच एज एचटीटीपी थ एटीटीपी
ओपन प्रॉक्सी हर एक स्क्रिप्ट इसका मतलब
यह हुआ कि मैं अब क्या करता हूं एलएस करता
हूं सिंपल यहां पे अब एलएस कर लिया अब
इसके बाद क्या करेंगे मुझे एचटीटीपी वाले
स्क्रिप्ट चाहिए मान लो तो मैं यहां प
सिंपल ग ग्रेप लगा देता हूं एचटीटीपी कर
देता हूं आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं तो आपको
एचटीटीपी वाले जो है यहां पे सारे जो
स्क्रिप्ट्स है वो यहां पर लिस्ट आउट हो
जाएंगे अब मुझे मान लो ऐसे भी मैं कर सकता
हूं ना एलएस करके एंड यहां पे मैं क्या कर
देता हूं अ
[संगीत]
http2 वाले जो स्क्रिप्ट्स हैं वह यहां पे
लिस्ट होके आ जाएंगे तो अब यह एटीटीपी के
आपके जो है लिस्ट होके आ गए तो अब एटीटीपी
में कौन-कौन से हैं देखो यहां पे एटीटीपी
ऑथ h ऑथ एेंसी एटीटीपी बैकअप एटीटीपी
ब्रूट अलग-अलग तरह के हैं यहां पे एटीटीपी
एनम ए अ यहां पे आपके एटीटीपी एनएम भी
यहां पे उसके बाद नीचे आओ एटीटीपी पासवर्ड
अलग-अलग तरह के एटीटीपी अ वी होस्ट वायरस
टोटर एटीपी व य देखो एटीपी वय एल वय एलन
जो है यह बेसिकली क्या है कि जो भी यह
सीवीज है आपके यह सीवी यह सीवी से रिलेटेड
जो अटैक्स है यह करेगा स्क्रिप्ट एंड उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के अंदर
में यह स्क्रिप्ट चला के आपको बताएगा कि
वह टारगेट इस पर्टिकुलर सीवी से अफेक्टेड
है कि नहीं
है बस अब ये कौन सा सीवी है मान लो मैंने
क्या किया मान लो यहां से कॉपी किया सीवी
एंड यहां प पेस्ट कर दी एंड एंटर कर दिया
अब यह सीवी यहां पे यह तो एनम की वो है
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे अ सी वल्नरेबल कौन सा है
ये ओके वेब मन बिफोर 1.2.9 यूजर मीन बिफोर
इतना कॉल्स द सिंपलीफाई पाथ फंक्शन बिफोर
डिकोडिंग ये लेबिलिटी थी जिसको ये
एक्सप्लोइट करता है सिंपल सा चीज है एंड
आपको वो प्रोवाइड करता है ठीक है तो ये
वनबिल को एक्सप्लोइट करता है ये सीवी तो
इससे व वल्नरेबल है कि नहीं ऐसे करके मतलब
हर एक सी भी तो हम पर्टिकुलर क्या यहां पे
वाइल्ड कार्ड यूज़ कर सकते हैं कैसे
एटीटीपी हान 1 एंड उसके बाद वाइल्ड कार्ड
यूज़ कर लीजिए दैट सट जैसे यहां पे
इन्होंने क्या यूज़ किया है ऑफिशियल में
जब आप
[संगीत]
जाओगे कहां गई ये वाली इस तरीके से तो
एटीटीपी हान यहां यूज़ किया है तो हान व
यूज़ करके एंड वाइल कार्ड यूज़ कर लो तो
आप यू यो वो यूज कर सकते हैं स्क्रिप्ट
ठीक है तो चलिए अब हम क्या करते हैं यहां
पे फिलहाल के लिए अपने आ जाते हैं मशीन पे
अब हम यहां पे यूज करना है किसी टारगेट के
अगेंस्ट में तो हमारे पास टारगेट कौन सा
है पहले टारगेट ले लेते हैं टारगेट ये
वाला तो नहीं था शायद टारगेट कोई और था ना
हमारा ये कोई टारगेट थी जो 503 या 501
शायद हमें एरर दे रहा
था बट दैट वाज वर्किंग राइट अ ओके यह वाली
तो यह टारगेट है हमारे पास तो इस टारगेट
को हमने कॉपी कर लिया एंड अब हम क्या करते
हैं ए मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन का यूज करने
वाले हैं ठीक है भैया तो हम क्या कर देते
हैं यहां पे कैसे हम प्रोवाइड करेंगे इसका
मैं आपको बता देता हूं किस तरीके से यूज
करने वाले हैं सिंपल सा पहले तो हम क्या
करेंगे एचटीटीपी वाले सारे हम यूज करने
वाले हैं तो हम यहां पे ए मैप यूज करेंगे
टारगेट को हम यहां पे मेंशन कर देंगे आप
एम के नॉर्मल कमांड के साथ आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं स्क्रिप्ट्स को कोई दिक्कत नहीं
जैसे अपन h एवी लगाते हैं ना स वजन के लिए
तो सर्विस वर्जन के लिए कर लो या तो किसी
पर्टिकुलर आप चाहते हो सिर्फ यूज करने के
लिए स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है तो हम य पर फिलहाल के लिए
ओनली हान टी सॉरी हान t4 यूज कर लेते हैं
हान हान स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर लेते हैं ठीक है
ना एंड स्क्रिप्ट जो है वह हम दे देते हैं
अब स्क्रिप्ट कौन सा देना है भैया तो हमें
यहां पर क्या कौन सा यह वाला वाइल्ड कार्ड
यूज कर लेना है
देखिए वी विल यूज दिस वाइल्ड काड
कहां गया भैया यार यह वाला यह वाला हम
वाइल्ड कार्ड यूज कर लेते हैं सिंपल सा
एटीटीपी हाइन वाला ठीक है तो अब क्या है
हमें वन वाला भी चाहिए हमें सिर्फ एटीटीपी
हाइन नहीं चाहिए हमें क्या चाहिए वन वाला
यूज करना है तो हम क्या करेंगे यहां पे
वाइल्ड कार्ड यूज करेंगे एटीटीपी
हान व तब हम यह वाइल्ड कार्ड यहां पे यूज
करने वाले हैं एंड देन हम डबल कोट यहां पे
इसको क्लोज कर देंगे
दैट्ची स्क्रिप्ट वो यूज हो जाने चाहिए
यहां पे एंड हमारा काम हो जाना चाहिए तो
अब हम इतना करके और एंटर करेंगे एंड लेट्स
सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग देखते हैं इफ वी आर
गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स लेट्स
सी वधान अ सर आई फाउंडेड हिरोक एपीआई की
इन अवर वेबसाइट एंड रिपोर्टेड थैंक यू फॉर
योर वंडरफुल क्लासेस कीप गोइंग थैंक यू सो
मच एंड यू आर डडूइंग ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशन
ठीक है कांग्रेचुलेशन हां हां डायरेक्ट
हान एससी यूज कर लो डीजे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है हान एसी यूज कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट से स्कैन कर देगा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हान एसी भी यूज कर सकते
हैं बट यहां पे मैं सारा तरीका बता रहा
हूं कि काइंड ऑफ कि हाउ यू कैन डू द
थिंग्स और कुछ नहीं तो यहां पे हमने ये
स्कैनिंग यहां पे हमने लगा दिया यहां पे
अब हम एक काम करते हैं यहां पे हान न
स्क्रिप्ट के जगह पे हम हान
स्क्रिप्ट एंड एडीबी व यह वाला लगा देते
हैं ठीक है लेट्स सी ओनली स्क्रिप्ट लगा
देते हैं क्या होता
है यस यस
यस यस यस यस राइट
राइट जनरली आप जब बेसिकली सीटीएफ वगैरह
करोगे तो हान t4 ही यूज करोगे आप हान t4
हटा भी सकते हो कोई बड़ी बात नहीं वो आपकी
आपकी मर्जी है मैं t4 यूली यूज करता हूं
कोई ज्यादा दिक्कत नहीं आएगी फिलहाल के
लिए एंड यहां पे हमने यहां पर क्या यूज
किया एडीपी यहां पर यूज कर लिया ठीक है वल
वाला यूज कर लिया बाकी आपको सारे एडीपी
वाले करने है तो सेम इस तरीके से एडी हान
यह सारा ही यूज कर लेगा ठीक है ट्स
इट हा फनन स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर लो या हान कर
लो आपकी मर्जी है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
दोनों ही ऑलमोस्ट काम करी जाती
है सो वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनीथिंग सो लेट्स
मैक्सिमाइज इट मैं यहां
पे हाइन स्क्रिप्ट एंड इस बार ए
पूरे ही एटीटीपी वाला यूज कर लेता हूं
लेटस सी कुछ मिलता है क्या टेंपरली
डिसेबल्ड ठीक है एटीपी रब टेक्स वाली जो
है यह डिसेबल हुआ है बाकी ठीक है बाकी यूज
कर लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है सर मुझे टॉप कंपनी में से एक कंपनी में
बग मिला है लाइक इतना नो रेट लिमिट ऑन
कमेंट सो इट इ वैलिड अगर नो रेट लिमिट कुछ
इंपैक्टफुल है तो ही वो वैलिड है अदर वाइज
वैलिड नहीं
है ट्राई करो रेट लिमिट जो है उसको बायपास
करने का अगर वो बायपास कर दिए तो वैलिड हो
जाएगी वो रेट लिमिट अगर बायपास
हुई ठीक
है लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग समथिंग हान
वीवी आप कर सकते हो जैसे ये जो चीजें कर
रहे हैं ना हम यहां पे आप हाई फन वीवी लगा
सकते हो तो आपको वर्वस जो मोड है इनेबल हो
जाएगा एंड ये आपको दिखाता जाएगा कि यह कर
क्या रहा है बेसिकली तो यहां पर यह
डिस्कवर्ड ओपन पोर्ट एंड य स्कैनिंग चालू
कर दिया इसने एंड बेसिकली यह इनीशिएट कर
रहा है यहां पर क्योंकि हमने टी फ लगाया
नहीं है तो यह काफी टाइम लेगा तो मैं यहां
पर हान t4 लगा ही देता हूं ताकि थोड़ा सा
स्पीड फास्ट हो जाएगा हमारा मैक्सिमम
ट्राइज मिनिमम रेट यह सब भी लगा सकते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है ठीक
है ओके इट्स डूइंग इट्स वर्क
सो यहां 5 पर हो रहा है तो यह चलेगा अपना
यह चलने देते हैं इसको तो एम स्क्रिप्टिंग
इंजन का ऐसे आप यूज कर सकते हो बहुत सारे
स्क्रिप्ट्स है यू कैन स्कैन विद दोज
स्क्रिप्ट्स आप उन स्क्रिप्ट्स के लिए उन
पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए आप स्कैन कर सकते हो
अब इसका रिजल्ट एक्चुअल रिजल्ट आपको देखना
है तो वो रिजल्ट मैं आपको दिखाता हूं यह
हम अपने लैब प कर सकते हैं ओबवियसली हमारा
जो मेटा स् पलटेबल है वहां आपको एक्चुअल
में दिख जाएगा जो भी रिजल्ट्स आ रही है तो
लेट्स ओपन द मेटा स्प्ला
टेबल ओन द
काली ओके लेट्स ओपन यह तो रियल टारगेट है
तो जैसा होगा वैसा ही आपको मिलेगा यहां प
तो ली थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा स्लो होगा यहां
पर तो आप यहां पर मिनिमम रेट वगैरह लगा
सकते हैं हाई फन हान मिन रेट जो आपको
मैंने बताया था हान मिन रेट मैक्स राइ वगर
लगा सकते हैं ठीक
है सरई बायपास 403 बट रीडायरेक्ट इन टू
होम पेज तो भाई 403 बायपास
अगर तुम कर भी रहे हो तो ओबवियसली
रीडायरेक्शन लगी होगी तो रीडायरेक्ट हो
रही है सिंपल तो बायपास नहीं हुआ ना कुछ
नहीं होगा ना उस परे पर्टिकुलर वहां पर
ट्स वा ठीक है तो यहां पर आपके यह चीज हो
रही है यह इसमें ओबवियसली टाइम लगेगा बट
हम इसको रियल रियल टारगेट प एक बार देख
लेते हैं एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ एडमिन एंड
आई एफ कॉन्फो इट्स 183 अगेन एंड काली में
आ जाते हैं काली में यहां पर आ जाते हैं
चलिए तो हम काली के अंदर आ चुके हैं अब
मैं आपको इसका रियल एग्जांपल दिखा देता
हूं एक बार ताकि आपको क्लियर हो जाए कि
एक्चुअली में यह होता क्या है इसके अंदर
में ठीक है तो हम यहां पर ओपन कर लेते हैं
टर्मिनल को इसको मैं जूम कर लेता हूं एंड
एन मैप मैं करता हूं यहां पर सिंपल एंड
यहां पर मैं सिंपल अगर टारगेट का देता हूं
29 138 एंड यहां पर हान एवी दे देते हैं
सर्विस के लिए तो आपको जब सर्विस डिटेल्स
मिलेगी यहां
पे अच्छा 83 है ना मैंने 138 डाल दिया है
तो यहां पे अब सर्विस की जो डिटेल आपको
मिलेगी तो आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा एम स्क्रिप्टिंग का कैसे आप यूज कर
सकते हो मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं तो यहां पे
आपको ये डिटेल्स मिल गई सर्विस की अब
इसमें क्या कर सकते हैं हान न स्क्रिप्ट
ठीक है और यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट लगा देते हैं
तो हम यहां पे जैसा यूज कर रहे थे ना
एचटीटीपी वाली एटीटीपी व वाली तो हम ये
वाली लगा देते हैं एंड यहां पे वाइल्ड
कार्ड लगा देते हैं ठीक है कार्ड लगा देते
हैं एंड यहां पे इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं
अब ये जो स्कैन करेगा तो इस पर्टिकुलर
स्क्रिप्ट जो एसटीपी व वाली जितनी भी
स्क्रिप्ट मैंने आपको दिखाई थी वो सारे
स्क्रिप्ट्स को रन करेगा इस पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट के लिए इसमें सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन भी करेगा एंड देन आपको रिजल्ट जो
है वो शो करेगा सो लेट्स
वेट लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट देखते हैं
99.7 पर हो चुका है बहुत बढ़िया लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज वी आर गेटिंग लाइव टारगेट पे भी
आपको सेम अप्रोच करना है ठीक है लैब में
और लाइव में बस यही अंतर होता है कि लाइव
लाइव है लाइब लैब है तो सारा कुछ बाकी सेम
होता
है सो वी
आर यह सारे स्क्रिप्ट्स को रन करेगा थोड़ा
टाइम तो लगेगा तो ओबवियसली ये थोड़ा टाइम
लग जाएगा आपको क्योंकि सारे ही स्क्रिप्ट
रन करेगा ये है ना 20 मिनट का एस्टिमेटर
टाइम दिखा रहा है आपको अभी तक ये देखो
यहां पे इसने दिया अब देखो यहां पे रिजल्ट
आ गया हमारे पास अब यहां पे देखो देखो
जैसे हमने स्क्रिप्ट एटीटीपी व वाला चलाया
ना तो हमें क्या मिला बाकी पोर्ट्स पे तो
कुछ नहीं मिलने वाले हैं ओबवियसली बट हमें
यहां पर नीचे आओगे तो यह एचटीटीपी सर्वर
जो एटी पोर्ट है आपका यहां पर सर्वर हेड
अचे 2.2.8 य2 एटीटीपी
सीवी 2017 यह वाला जो सीवी है भैया यह
वाला यहां पर अफेक्टेड पाया गया है एंड
पाया गया है कि भैया हमारा जो है यह
वल्नरेबल हो सकता है काइंड ऑफ समथिंग सो
व्हाट इज दिस
सीवी लेट्स कॉपी
इट लेट्स ओपन
इट लेट्स लेट्स लेट्स ओपन
इट ये सीवी आ गई आपके पास तो यह रही हमारी
सीवी एनएसटी वेबसाइट की डिटेल की प आपकी
डिटेल मिल जाती है सीवी इस
की ठीक है एंड वी गट द यर डिस्क्रिप्शन
यहां पे आ रहा है यहां पे सीवियरटी आपको
सीवीएसएस 3.1 सिरिटी आपको मिली हुई है
यहां पे एंड बेस स्कोर 7 प हाई का है यहां
पे ठीक है एंड बेसिकली यहां पे आपको इसके
अलग-अलग रेफरेंसेस मिल जा रहे हैं ठीक है
एंड यहां पे मैं कोई से भी रेफरेंस अगर
ओपन कर लूं तो अपन देख सकते हैं वर्डप्रेस
वेब एपीआई लेबिलिटी करके है ये ठीक है ना
वर्डप्रेस वेब एपीआई से रिलेटेड यह सीवी
है एंड ये सीवी का यही वर्डप्रेस से
रिलेटेड कुछ इसमें है लाइक यहां पे आपको
दिख सकता होगा द रजिस्टर राउट फंक्शन इन
डब्ल्यूपी इंक्लूड्स रेस्ट एपीआई एंड
पॉइंट्स क्लास डब्ल्यूपी टेस्ट अ रेस्ट
पोस्ट कलर पीएपी इनरे एपीआई इन वर्डप्रेस
4.7.1 बिफोर 4.7.2 डज नॉट रिक्वायर एन
इंटी जर
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
यहां पे हुआ था तो ये पर्टिकुलर वनबिल जो
है ये वलने टेबल जो है यहां पे ये दिखा
रहा है कि हां भैया ये स्क्रिप्ट से ये
वल्नरेबल है तो इस तरीके से आप यहां पे
स्कैनिंग कर सकते हो अब मान लो इसी तरीके
से मैं लोकेट करता हूं डॉट एनएसी करता हूं
यहां पे तो यह सारे आ गए यहां पे अब मुझे
कुछ और भी चाहिए कोई एक और रन करनी है मान
लो मुझे इसमें चाहिए ग्रिप मैं कर देता
हूं हु इज हु इज से रिलेटेड कोई स्क्रिप्ट
है हां है तो मैं सेम कमांड में यहां पे
अब मैं यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट
में सेम स्क्रिप्ट में आप ऐसे भी डाल सकते
हो ये हु इज डोमेन या हु इज आईपी तो आईपी
हमारी तो हम हु इज आईपी यूज कर लेते हैं
एंड ये स्क्रिप्ट यहां पे डाल देते हैं हम
सिंपल यहां पे एंटर कर देते हैं लेट्स से
इट शुड बी गिविंग द रिजल्ट्स हु इज रिजल्ट
ऑफ दिस पर्टिकुलर आईपी कुछ भी जो भी
रिजल्ट आएगा आपको दे देना चाहिए ठीक है सो
लेट्स
सी ठीक है तो हम यहां पे रिजल्ट आ चुका है
एंड यहां पे कुछ रिजल्ट आए कि हुज का कुछ
ऐसा कुछ खास रिजल्ट यहां नहीं आया चलिए हम
अपने मेन हम अपने क्लाउड पे देख लेते हैं
यहां पे ये अभी तक 7 पर हुआ देख रहे हो
कितना टाइम
लगेगा तो यहां पे हम यहां पे लोकेट कर
लेते हैं डॉट एनएसी एंड ग्रेप कर लेते हैं
सॉरी
सॉरी लोकेट कर लेते हैं डॉट एनसी ग्रेप कर
लेते हैं ग्रेप में क्या कर लेते हैं
ग्रेप में हम कर लेते हैं हु
इज ठीक है एंड प्रीवियस कमांड जो हमारा था
एन मैप का हमारा यह वाला कमांड था तो
इसमें हम स्क्रिप्ट को चेंज कर देते हैं
ओबवियसली सो वी आर जस्ट चेंजिंग द
स्क्रिप्ट ए स्क्रिप्ट में हम डाल देते
हैं यह वाला इ आईपी वाली हु इज आईपी ड
एएसी एंड बाकी सारी चीजें सेम रखते हैं
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग सो इट्स डूइंग
इट्स वर्क अपना काम कर रहा है स्क्रिप्ट
प्री स्कैनिंग लोडेड वन स्क्रिप्ट फॉर
स्कैनिंग एक स्क्रिप्ट लोड हुई है यहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे स्कैनिंग यह
पोर्ट ओपन यह चेक कर रहा है ऑब्
वियस डिस्कवर्ड ओपन पोर्ट्स क्योंकि बाय
डिफॉल्ट एससी जो है आपका एसएस सॉरी एसएस
जो टीसीपी सिन स्कैन है बाय डिफॉल्ट लेता
है आपका एंड यहां पे यह रिजल्ट जो है वो आ
चुकी है यहां पे आपने यहां पर देखा 8443
अब यहां पे होस्ट स्क्रिप्ट रिजल्ट जो
आपने स्क्रिप्ट यूज किया उसका रिजल्ट आपको
मिल चुका है तो हु इज आईपी रिकॉर्ड जो है
मिला है यह
किसी यह किसी एलिंग कंप्यूटिंग को लिमिटेड
का है यह आईपी एंड ये इनकी ईमेल आईडी
वगैरह है ये इनकी ईमेल आईडी है इस तरीके
से तो ये आपको रिजल्ट इस तरीके से मिल
जाते हैं ठीक है अब ऐसे ही पर्टिकुलर
सीवीज के अगेंस्ट में आप स्क्रिप्ट्स रन
कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग चीजें कर कर सकते हैं
ठीक है आपको बहुत अच्छा वहां पे रिजल्ट
मिल जाता है तो आप अगर देखोगे अगर तो मैं
लोकेट कमांड से ड एनए स्क्रिप्ट देखूंगा
तो आपको बहुत सारे अलग-अलग कैटेगरी के
आपको मिलेंगे तो चलिए मैं काम करता हूं
लेट्स लेट्स एलएस एंड स् एसआर शेयर ए मैप
स्क्रिप्ट्स एंड एंटर अब देखिए यहां पे
कितने तरह के स्क्रिप्ट्स है यहां पे आप
देखिए यहां पे मैं लेके चलता हूं ऊपर आपको
लेट्स
सी टकटुक गो टू डू ये देखो यहां पे
अलग-अलग तरह के स्क्रिप्ट्स यहां पे
ऑथेंटिकेशन से बिटकॉइन बैनर बैनर ग्रैबिंग
के लिए आप बैनर का यूज कर सकते हो बैनर
ग्रैबिंग जिसको आप बोलते हो अगर नहीं पता
तो थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा बैनर ग्रैबिंग
क्या होता है आपको पता चल जाएगा ठीक है ना
यहां पे ब्रॉडकास्ट से रिलेटेड यहां पे है
यहां पे
आपका सीवीएसएस सीवीएस ब्रूट ब्रूट
रिपोजिटरी ये एक है आपका जिसका यूज कर
सकते हैं सीवीएस ब्रूट है यहां पे डीएनएस
से रिलेटेड स्क्रिप्ट्स है डीएनएस ब्रू
डीएनएस कैश डीएनएस चेक जोन डीस जोन
ट्रांसफर से भी रिलेटेड है सब चीज यहां प
लाइक आल्सो यहां पर फायरवॉल एफटीपी एफटीपी
से रिलेटेड भी यहां पर स्कैनस है ठीक है
अब जैसे देखो य एफटीपी से रिलेटेड है ना
ये स्क्रिप्ट है एफटीपी से रिलेटेड अब हम
सेम अगर हम अपने एफटीपी चलो एफटीपी वाला
वाइल्ड कार्ड आपको यूज करके दिखाता हूं
देखो आपको थोड़ा रिलेट शायद आप कर पाओगे
अब यहां पर मैं सेम स्क्रिप्ट यूज कर रहा
हूं अब यहां पर मैं स्क्रिप्ट को मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं यहां पर एफटीपी वाले यूज कर
लेते हैं
एफटीपी ट्स इट ठीक है तो जितने भी एफटीपी
वाले स्क्रिप्ट्स हैं हमारे तो कौन से हैं
एफटीपी वाले दिखा दो लेट्स सी ई
ए यह रहा एफटीपी तो सिंपल एफटीपी भी है
क्या कुछ एफटीपी एनन है एफटीपी हां ठीक है
एफटीपी डैश एफटीपी डैश वाला हम यूज कर
लेते हैं वाइल्ड कार्ड यहां पे लगा देते
हैं एक बार तो एफटीपी डैश एंड यहां वाइल
काड लगा दो यहां पे एंड
दैट्ची ठीक है
ट बनर ग्रबिंग कैन बी डन विथ नेट कट बट यू
कैन आल्सो यूज दिस अगर आप एप यूज करो उस
समय यूज कर सकते
हो ठीक
है सर ऐसा कोई नहीं है जो लाइव टारगेट में
अरे बाप रे
धन्यवाद एफटीपी बाउंस पोर्ट रिस्पांस 500
इलीगल पोर्ट कमांड ठीक है दूसरे पर आ जाते
हैं इसको आप देख भी सकते हो हान व लगा ते
तो आपको रियल में दिखता रियल टारगेट आपको
दिखता जाएगा जैसे मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
हान वीवी लगा दो तो यह एकदम पूरा कंप्लीट
आपको दिखेगा डिस्कवर्ड ओपन पोर्ट्स
स्कैनिंग 23
सर्विसेस यह सारी चीजें है
ना मैं रिवील करूंगा बहुत सारी चीजें
टेंशन नहीं लो आप
लोग ठीक है यह हो रही
है लेट्स लेट्स लेट्स
लेट्स लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग 98
पर
अभी अब बहुत जल्द आप लोगों का बहुत शानदार
मतलब बहुत बहुत शानदार चीजें स्टार्ट होने
वाली है ठीक है तो ध्यान रखिएगा एक्सेसेस
हो गया सीएसआरएफ हो
गई लाइक एसएसआरएफ हो गया आपका
एचटीटीपी लाइक पैरामीटर टैंपरिंग हो गई
आपकी ठीक है तो एवरीथिंग विल स्टार्ट वेरी
सून सब धीरे धीरे धीरे धीरे आएगा आपके पास
तो आपको टेंशन नहीं लेना बिल्कुल भी सब
चीज आएंगी भाई सब चीजें आएंगी धीरे-धीरे
ठीक है तो ये स्क्रिप्ट्स स्क्रिप्ट्स रन
हो रहे हैं यहां पे जितने भी एसीडीपी वाले
हैं एफटीपी वाले वो सारे स्क्रिप्ट्स रन
होंगे यहां पे ठीक है एंड इट विल गिव यू द
रिजल्ट्स सर दिस क्लास अपलोड योर
हमें क्या है यार हम तो जब तक हमें कोई
कुछ बोलेगा नहीं तब तक हम क्यों कुछ
बोले
यप कोर्स में कर चुके हो तो तुम अभी शांत
रहो थोड़ी देर जब तक कुछ नया नहीं आ जाता
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है है ना जो लोग कर चुके
हैं जो लोगों को जो चीज पता है उनके लिए
नहीं है वो पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक आप उस टॉपिक
को स्किप कर सकते हो फिर जो चीज नहीं आती
है उसमें आप आ सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
ठीक है
मतलब यहां सिर्फ एक बंदे के लिए नहीं हो
रही है ये क्लास यह उन लोगों के लिए हो
रही है जिनको बिल्कुल नहीं आता या फिर
जिनको नहीं मिल पाती फ्री में क्लासेस
फ्री में रिसोर्सेस फ्री में मेंटरशिप
नहीं मिल पाती है सही से ऑथेंटिक और
जेनुइन मेंटरशिप उनके लिए है ये याद
रखिएगा ठीक है
आगे बहुत मजा आएगा अभी तो भाई अभी तो
शुरूआत
है अरे कितने वेटिंग है
यार 20 मिनट दिखा रहा है य भी काफी टाइम
लग जाएगा यार जस्ट लीव इट आन t5 यूज कर लू
क्या बहुत ज्यादा फास्ट हो जाएगा बट देखते
हैं टी फ यूज करके लेट्स सी हाउ मच फास्ट
स् देखते हैं टी फ कितना फास्ट
है चलो धन्यवाद
भाई बग क्लास कब आएगी भाई यह सब बग की ही
क्लास चल रही है टेंशन मत लो यह सब बग की
ही क्लास चल रही है मेरे
भैया
t5 इज वेरी फास्ट लेट्स
वेट चलिए तो यह तो हो रहा है काली में हो
रहा है इसको काली में होने देते हैं अब हम
यहां पे पहले वीपीएस प आ जाते हैं हम आगे
भी चीजें करते हैं एंड इसको भी हम देख
लेंगे यहां पे ये आपने ए मैप स्क्रिप्ट्स
देख लिए ये एन मैप स्क्रिप्ट्स आप चला
सकते हैं एंड इन पे अलग-अलग तरह की
स्क्रिप्ट्स है यहां पे हर एक चीज के लिए
स्क्रिप्ट्स हैं आप उनको यूज कर सकते हैं
एक टारगेट के अग सिंपल एक एक जो तरीका है
मैंने आपको तरीका देखो मैं तरीका बताता
मैं आपको स्पून फिडिंग कभी नहीं करूंगा कि
लो भैया चम्मच से खा लो ऐसे करना है ऐसे क
चला लो ना भाई ना वो चीज कभी नहीं हो
पाएगी तो यह आपको देखो क्या करना है एन
मैप कमांड डालनी है सिंपल टारगेट डालना है
टारगेट को आप लिस्ट में भी डाल सकते हो इफ
यू वांट यू कैन पुट द टारगेट सब डोमेंस की
लिस्ट डाल सकते हो हान आईल स्विच लगा सकते
हो ए मैप के अंदर टारगेट डाल दो हान न
स्क्रिप्ट डालनी है और ए मैप की जो
स्क्रिप्ट एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट यूज करनी है
वो डालना है एंड अब बाकी के ऑप्शन जो आप
डालना चाहते हो सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन भी
करना चाहते हो या जो भी करना चाहते हो सब
डाल दो सब चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ट्स
इट समझ में आ गया ये वाली चीज समझ में आ
गई ये चीज समझ में आ गई सबको इतना बता
दीजिए मुझे एन मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग इंज यूज
कर लोगे आप मेरा बताने का मोटिव ये
बिल्कुल नहीं है कि मैं एकएक चीज आपको एन
मैप का एकएक चीज ऐसे अरे अरे मुंह खोलो ये
एन मैप का स्क्रिप्टिंग खा लो अरे अरे
मुंह खोलो ये स्क्रिप्ट खा लो ऐसा नहीं
बताऊंगा यार आपको तरीका बताता हूं गाइड कर
रहा हूं एक रास्ता दिखा रहा हूं उस रास्ते
प चलो एक्सप्लोर करो प्रो बक माउंटी हंटर
नहीं बनोगे तब क्या करो यार बनोगे यार
100% बनोगे नहीं क्यों नहीं बनोगे
बनोगे वन आई स्टार्ट दिस जर्नी आई टूक योर
फ्री वेबीनार आई वाज इन लव विथ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी थैंक यू अहमद राजा अच्छा लगा
मुझे आपको अच्छा लग रहा है तो ट्स ग्रेट
चलिए ग्रेट
ग्रेट
ओके एक्सेसेस आग स्टार्ट होगी बहुत जल्दी
आपको टाइटल में मिल जाएगा जब भी स्टार्ट
होगी आपको टाइटल में मिल जाएगा एक्सस का
ठीक
है बट आप लोग रिप्लाई नहीं करते हो यार जो
मैं पूछता हूं ये बड़ी दुख की बात है
रिप्लाई तो कर दिया करो कि क्या है क्या
नहीं है रिप्लाई तो कर दिया करो यार बड़ी
दुख की बात होती है चलिए अब गाइस यहां पे
एक दो टूल सेट्स के बारे में हम जानने
वाले हैं हम समझने वाले हैं समझिए आप लोग
चैट में यार चैट से इधर आ जाइए थोड़ा सा
प्लीज कम हियर थोड़ा सा इधर मेरे साइड आइए
यहां पर एंड समझिए इस चीज को हम अब यहां
पर थोड़ा सा हां हां वेब वाले भाई वेब
वाले ही आएंगे टेंशन नहीं लेने का यार तना
टेंशन लोगे तो कैसे काम चलेगा है
ना ठीक है अब हम यहां पर एक टूल का यूज
करने वाले हैं वी आर गोइंग टू यूज अ
टूल जिसको हम बोलते हैं सैंड मैप जिसको हम
बोलते हैं सैंड मैप यह क्या है यह एन मैप
ऑन स्टी
एन मैप को जब तुम स्टीरियो पर डाल दोगे तो
वह सैंड मैप बन जाता है क्या है यह यह टूल
हालांकि बहुत बढ़िया है टूल अच्छा टूल है
वैसे पूरी की पूरी सेल स्क्रिप्टिंग में
बनी हुई है यह टूल तो आप अभी मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं कैसे यह यूज होता है एन मैप
सॉरी सड मैप इज अ टूल सपोर्टिंग नेटवर्क
एंड सिस्टम रॉनेस यूजिंग द मैसिव एन मैप
इंजन इट्स प्रोवाइड यूजर इंटरफेस यूजर
इंटरफेस फ्रेंडली यूजर इंटरफेस ऑटोमेट्स
एंड स्पीड्स ऑफ द स् एंड अलाउ यू टू इजली
यूज मेनी एडवांस स्कैनिंग टेक्निक्स ठीक
है तो आप इसको यूज कर सकते हो बहुत सिंपल
सा कैसे गिट क्लोन कर लेना है यह वाला
सीडी सड मैप में चले जाना है एंड सेटअप ड
एस इंस्टॉल कर लेना है सिंपल तो पहले क्या
कर लेना है आपको गट गिट गिट क्लोन कर लेना
है तो चलिए हम अपने सवर प चलते हैं यहां
पे यह कमांड चलाना है आपका गिट क्लोन हो
जाएगा उसके बाद एक डायरेक्टरी बन जाएगी सड
मैप की तो यहां पे
मैं स
मैप ये डायरेक्टरी आपको दिख गई अब हम इस
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
मिलेंगी यहां पे इसमें सेटअप ड एसए मिल
जाएगा एक फाइल मिल जाएगी अलग-अलग
डायरेक्टरी मिल जाएंगी हमें इस फाइल को
एग्जीक्यूट कर देना है कैसे एग्जीक्यूट
करना है भैया यहां पे दे रखा है डॉट से
अपड एंड इंस्टॉल यानी कि आपको चलाना है
इंस्टॉल करने के लिए टसे अपड ए इंस्टॉल बस
जैसे ही ये चलाओगे इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा आपका
सिम लिंक बन जाएगा यूजर लोकल बिन में आपका
इसका
जो बिन फाइल मतलब सॉरी जो बाइनरी फाइल है
वह चली जाएगी उसके बाद आप सिंपल सैंड मैप
करके और एंटर करेंगे तो आपका ये लच हो
जाएगा नफन हेल्प लिखिए तो इसकी हेल्प फाइल
ओपन हो जाएगी इसके हेल्प फाइल में आपको
ज्यादा कुछ मिलेगा नहीं आपको इसके
रिपोजिटरी पर यहां पर आके आपको सारी डिटेल
जो है व चेक
आउट कर लेनी है अब इसको यूज कैसे करना है
जैसे मेरे पास एक टारगेट है जैसे मेरे पास
एक टारगेट है टारगेट कौन सा भैया
वही य वाला टारगेट ही रख लेते हैं यह
हमारा टारगेट
है ठीक है यहां पर कुछ हमें मिला है क्या
कुछ नहीं मिला मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं
यहां से मैं एग्जिट कर देता
हूं सड मैप के अंदर में यूज अगर करना है
तो आपको सिंपली चलानी क्या है सैंड मैप
ऐसे लिखना है सैंड मैप और एंटर कर देना है
एंटर करते ही सेड मैप अपने सारे मॉड्यूस
को एंटर करेगा ठीक
है गिट टूल लिस्ट इन चैट अरे भैया चैट में
क्यों चाहिए गिट अप की टूल की लिस्ट मैंने
यार सीधा-सीधा आपको बताया तो सड मैप ऐसे
टाइप करो ना यार सड मैप गिट हब ऐसे टाइप
करा करो और यहां पर देखो यह वीडियो में
देखा करो कौन सी रिपोजिटरी है बस उस पर
चले जाओ चलो बोल दिया है तो मैं दे देता
हूं तुम्हे चैट में बाकी यार तुम लोग यार
क्या यार टेंशन ले रहे हो यार ठीक है
ओके डन डन भैया डन डन भैया अब यहां पर
क्या कर देते हैं यहां पे टाइम आउट चलिए
ओके अब हम यहां पे ए s मैप को ओपन कर चुके
हैं अब यहां पर कुछ इस तरीके से आपका इसका
इंटरफेस आ जाएगा ओके कुछ इस तरीके से
इंटरफेस आया मैं इसको यहां पे क्लियर कर
देता हूं अब यहां पे जब आपको हेल्प फाइल
करोगे हेल्प टाइप करोगे एंटर करोगे यू विल
टाइप हेल्प एंटर तो आपको ये सारे ऑप्शंस
मिल जाएंगे जो ऑप्शंस आप इसके साथ यूज कर
सकते हो तो हेल्प है लिस्ट है लिस्ट में
शो अवेलेबल मॉड्यूस शो तो शो अवेलेबल
मॉड्यूल तो चलो शो कर लेते हैं कौन-कौन से
मॉड्यूस है भाई शो शो करोगे तो अभी कुछ
नहीं मिल रहा है कोई बात नहीं यहां लिस्ट
से शो अवेलेबल मॉड्यूल अच्छा लिस्ट करने
से ना लिस्ट करते हैं लिस्ट करेंगे तो
आपको सारे मॉड्यूल जो है यहां पर आपको मिल
जाएंगे अब ये देखिए सारे मॉड्यूस कौन-कौन
से मॉड्यूस है ऑसम मॉड्यूस यहां पे जो
है ऑसम य होस्ट डिस्कवरी एनएससी
ब्रॉडकास्ट एन साइ ट्रिक्स ए डेटाबेस
एक्सटर्नल
एनएससी ये स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजीन वाले एफटीपी
के हैं ये एचटीटीपी के हैं डूब के हैं ये
एनएससी स्क्रिप्ट्स है उसके बाद यहां पे
ओएस डिटेक्शन है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग है सर्विस
डिटे यह सारी चीज चलो अब मान लो मुझे क्या
करना है मुझे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी है मान
लो लेट्स सपोज पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी है तो
मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पर पहले तो एक
टारगेट को सेट कर दूंगा अगर आपको देखना
यहां पर ऊपर में हेल्प फाइल हमने देखा
होगा तो अगर कोई मॉड्यूल का आपको इंफो
चाहिए तो शो एंड मॉड्यूल आपको डाल देना है
तो मैं य करूंगा शो एंड मुझे मॉड्यूल का
इंफो चाहिए पोर्ट स्कैन का तो पोर्ट
अंडरस्कोर स्कैन ये कर दिया एंटर कर दिया
तो पोर्ट स्कैन के फॉर्मेशन आ गई यहां पे
कि भैया यहां पर क्या हो रहा है अब यह
सारी चीजें आप कर सकते हैं पोर्ट स्कैन के
साथ बस सिंपल सा ये फंडा है ठीक है इसके
साथ में शो पोर्ट स्कैन करके अब मुझे मान
लो यूज करना है पोर्ट स्कैन को तो मैं
क्या करूंगा यूज पोर्ट स्कैन ऐसे कर लूंगा
और एंटर कर लूंगा पोर्ट स्कैन वाले में
मैं चला गया मैं पोर्ट स्कैन वाले आराम से
उसके अंदर चला गया ठीक
है ओके पोर्ट स्कैन में आ गए हम अब हम
यहां पर क्या कर देंगे शो सॉरी यहां पर
अगर हम शो करते हैं शो तो यहां पर आपको
इसके ऑप्शन दिख जाएंगे ठीक है अब यहां पर
हमें टारगेट सेट करना है तो इसके लिए हमें
यूज करना होता है सेट डेस्टिनेशन तो हमें
सेट डेस्टिनेशन करना है और जो हमारा आईपी
है वह आईपी डाल देना है तो चलिए हमारा
आईपी कौन सा था भैया अगेन वी विल
सी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी यह आईपी थी यह
वाली ओके तो हमने यहां पर टारगेट आईपी दे
दी चलो टारगेट आईपी हमने दे दी डेस्टिनेशन
हमारा सेट हो गया अब हमें क्या इनिशिएटिव
तो आप इसका नंबर जो है आईडी चार ऐसे लिख
दो दोनों में से कोई सा भी लिख दो ये
बेसिकली नल स्कैन कमांड आपका ये एन मैप
वाला ही चलाएगा जो आपको यहां पे दिख रहा
होगा n मैप कमांड बट ये कंपैरेटिव थोड़ा
सा आपको ना बढ़िया फास्ट थोड़ा सा आपको
आउटपुट दे सकता है तो आप इसको यूज कर सकते
हो फॉर पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट स्कैनिंग सर्विस
डिटेक्शन इस तरीके की चीजों के लिए तो
यहां पे हमने सिंपल सा ये नल स्कैन चलाया
है तो ये सिंपल सा नल स्कैन आपका आ जाएगा
एंड यहां पे आपको आ रहा है रिजल्ट आपको आ
रहा है ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं शो कर देता
हूं एंड यहां पे अब मुझे इट करना है एंड
मुझे अगर करना है
अ लेट्स सपोज टीसीपी सिन स्कैन ठीक है तो
मैं क्या करूंगा जीरो आईडी एंड एंटर कर
दूंगा तो ये टीसीपी सिन स्कैन को स्टार्ट
कर देगा और इसके रिजल्ट दे देगा ठीक है तो
ये भी काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है अच्छा टूल
है आप इसको यूटिलाइज कर सकते हो अलग-अलग
काम के लिए ठीक है तो ये हमारा यहां पे ये
आ जाएगा देखो
अभी एंटर करोगे तो आपको ओबवियसली वही
रिजल्ट आएगी तो ये देखिए यहां पे ये
रिजल्ट आपके पास आ गया अब मुझे वापस से
बैक जाना है तो मेन मैं कमांड टाइप
करूंगा बैक हो जाऊंगा यहां पे लिस्ट कर
दूंगा अगेन अ लिस्ट कर दूंगा तो अगेन मुझे
ये सारी लिस्ट मिल जाएंगी अब मुझे मान लो
यूज करना है सर्विस डिटेक्शन का तो मैं
यूज कर लूंगा सर्विस डिटेक्शन डिटेक्शन
एंड अब मुझे शो करना है इसके अंदर की सारी
क्या क्या चीजें मैं कर सकता हूं तो वर्जन
डिटेक्शन मोर अग्रेसिव करना है लाइट करना
है बैनर करना है वर्जन ऑल करना है कौन सा
करना है आपको आप लगा सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं तो मुझे मान लो सेट टारगेट सेट
डेस्टिनेशन कर देता हूं मैं एंड यहां पे
सॉरी ओके अब मैं यहां पे सेट डेस्टिनेशन
कर देता हूं एंड हमारा जो डे जो
हमारा टारगेट है वो टारगेट मेंशन कर देता
हूं यहां पे ठीक है सो आई एम जस्ट
मेंशनिंग द टारगेट हियर तो ये हमारा
डेस्टिनेशन सेट हो जाएगा ठीक है
डेस्टिनेशन सेट हो गया अब हम यहां पे
स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं क्या स्टार्ट कर सकते
हैं इट कर सकते हैं एंड अगर मुझे चाहिए
वर्जन डिटेक्शन नॉर्मल सा तो जीरो करूंगा
मुझे इंटेंसिटी फाइव वाला चाहिए मोर
एग्रेसिव तो मैं वन कर दूंगा तो ये मोर
एग्रेसिव वाला जो है कमांड चला देगा आप
देख सकते हैं एफ 51 sb1 वर्जन इंटेंसिटी
तो मतलब ये यूजर फ्रेंडली थोड़ा हो गया
थोड़ा आपके लिए इजी हो गया जैसे आपको अगर
कमांड्स याद नहीं करने ऐसा कुछ ऐसा तो आप
ये काम कर सकते हो अदर वाइज मैं आपको
मैनुअली ही बोलूंगा कि गो फॉर द मैनुअल
अप्रोच इजी बनाने के लिए टूल आप यूज कर
सकते हो ठीक है आई होप एवरीवन इज
गेटिंग तो कितने परसेंट हो गए यहां पे 50
पर हो चुका है अब आपको रिजल्ट आ जाएगा ठीक
है एक चीज और आपको बता देता हूं गाइस यहां
पे ये आ चुका है यहां पे देखो यहां पे
रिजल्ट हमें मिला यहां पे सेम चीज में
यहां पर अब यह एटीटीपी ओपन य आ रहा है
सर्विस फिंगर प्रिंटिंग आ गई यहां पर
बेसिकली यह क्योंकि हमने क्या किया था
इंटेंसिटी बढ़ा दिया था तो इसका सारा
डिटेल जो यहां पर मिल चुका है इस तरीके से
यू कैन यूटिलाइज दिस टूल ठीक है अब मान लो
मुझे यह तो हमने यूज कर लिया थोड़ा आसान
बनाने के लिए मैंने यह टूल बताया अब एक और
टूल आपको बता देता
हूं लेट्स
ओपन कोई साथ में करता है कि नहीं भाई आप
में से ये बताओ मुझे यार आप में से कोई
साथ में करते भी हो कि नहीं पता नहीं
कितने लोग करते हैं चलते हैं स्कैन अ
स्कैन कैनन आई थिंक गिट हब स्पेलिंग देख
लेना ये वाला स्कैन कैनन ये भी एक अच्छी
टूल है आप इस पे आओगे तो यहां पे लिखा
रहेगा ये सिंपल ये क्या करता है हैंडल्स द
न्यूमरेशन ऑफ लार्ज एज नेटवर्क्स एट हाई
स्पीड इसकी न्यूमरेशन करता है ठीक है क्या
करता है ये देखिए यहां पे यूजेस मास स्कैन
टू क्विकली
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
स्क्रिप्टिंग में बनी है बस स्क्रिप्टिंग
की गई है मास स्कैन का यूज करके पहले ये
पता लगाता है ओपन पोर्ट्स के लिए
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
स्कैनिंग वगैरह करता है तो यानी मास स्कैन
और ए मैप दोनों काम आप एक टूल के साथ इसके
साथ कर चुके हैं और ये बड़े नेटवर्क्स के
साथ बड़े सीआइडिया रेंज पे भी आप स्कैनिंग
कर सकते हो इसका यूज़ करके इसलिए लिए बहुत
ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है जैसे इसका यूज क्या
है सिंपल स्कन कनड ए और उसके बाद जो आपकी
सीआईडीआर फाइल है वो सीआईडीआर फाइल दे
देनी है ट्स इट सिंपल तो मान लो मेरे
पास सॉरी यह रिजल्ट आया क्या कुछ
इसका हा हमें यहां पर रिजल्ट्स आए हैं तो
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं वी गॉट द
रिजल्ट्स हियर एक तो यहां पे मिला हमें यह
देखो एफटीपी वाली जो हमने चलाई थी ना
एफटीपी वाली कमांड यह वाली एफटीपी
स्क्रिप्ट चलाई थी हमारे टारगेट मेटा स्
पलटेबल के लिए उसका रिजल्ट हमें मिल चुका
है एंड यहां पे आप जब नीचे आओगे नीचे आओगे
तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा यहां पे यह
देखो पट 21 के लिए यह बता रहा है एफटीपी
वीएस एफटीपीडी बैक डोर वल्नरेबल है 2.3.4
से इसकी पूरी डिटेल आपको यहां पे आ रही है
रीज़न आपको आ रहा है सब कुछ आ रहा है यहां
पे तो एक यह वलने बिटी आपको इसको जो है
मिली है एफटीपी एनोनिमस एफटीपी लॉगिन
अलाउड एनोनिमस एटी लॉगिन जो है वो भी
अलाउड है तो यह आपको मिला
है ठीक है सर्विस स्टेटस यहां पे आ रहा है
लगड इन लो लगड इन हो चुका है यहां पे बाकी
चीजें तो हमें और कुछ यहां पर खास मिली
नहीं है तो एफटीपी वाला रिजल्ट हमें यहां
पे इस तरीके से मिल चुका है ठीक है चलिए
बढ़िया अब यहां पे हम आ जाते हैं
एंड जी हां तो अब मैं आपको क्या दिखा रहा
था पावर ऑफ दिस दिस वन स्कन कैनन ठीक है
स्कन कैनन का
चलिए तो इसको यूज कैसे करना है स्कन कैनन
को सिंपली यहां से कॉपी कर लीजिएगा मतलब
गिट क्लोन करने के लिए आपको सिंपली यहां
से कॉपी कीजिए एंड यहां पर आप गिट क्लोन
एंड यह कर दीजिएगा एंटर कर दीजिएगा तो
आपका स्कन कैनन जो है यहां पर एक
डायरेक्टरी बन जाएगी यह देखिए है यह रही
इस डायरेक्टरी में चले जाना है स्कन कन के
अंदर में एलस करेंगे तो एलस करेंगे तो
आपको स्न कनड ए मिल जाएगी एंड इसके अंदर
एक सीआई पटी फाइल दिया इन्होंने इसी में
सीआईडीआर आपकी रहनी चाहिए जैसे हमारे पास
एल की एक सीआईडीआर है जैसे मैं करता हूं
एलस स्ल एलस कर दिया
हमने एल एल के अंदर चलते हैं एल के अंदर
यहां पर अगर मैं एलस करूं तो यहां पर एल c
आपको मिल जाएगी फाइल ठीक है ना भैया तो
इसको हम
apple.id में भेज देते हैं एज सिंपल एज
दैट
राइट तो भेज देते हैं कोई बात नहीं तो
यहां पे कर देते हैं एल सीआईडीआर को भेजते
हैं यहां पे सो
कैट एल एल
सीआईडीआर डटी एंड इसको भेज देते हैं सटी
में ठीक है तो हमने इसको भेज दिया यहां पे
अब हमें जो सीआईटी एक्सटी मिलेगी यहां पे
यह एल वाली सीआईडीआर होगी रेंज होगी तो
कैट सटी
एंड डब्लू सन
ए 1334 13 300 सॉरी 1314 1314 यहां पे
सीआईडीआर मिल चुकी है अगर आप देखना चाहोगे
तो आप देख सकते हो
आईपी वाले पे जो जो चाहे 80 हो 440 कोई भी
हो एन मैप चलाएंगे सर्विस वर्जन के लिए
एंड सोचो सोचो कि पूरा ऑटोमेट हो जाएगा
आपका एंड फिर आपको रिजल्ट मिलेगा तो इसमें
ओबवियसली टाइम बहुत लगेगा इवन यू आर ऑन
वीपीएस बट वर्थ होगा इसका जो आउटपुट होगा
ठीक है कुछ ना कुछ आपको मिल सकता है तो
इसको यूज कैसे करेंगे
स्कैन ये क्या है डॉट
स्न कनड ए एंड इसमें हमें फाइल पा पास
करनी है सीआ बस यही ऑप्शन था यही फंडा था
ना शायद देख लेते हैं एक
बार वे स्कन कनन डॉट ठीक है हां इसके पहले
आपके अंदर सिस्टम में मास स्कैन एंड मैप
यह दोनों इंस्टॉल्ड होने चाहिए भैया याद
रखिएगा और कुछ इसके लाइक रिक्वायरमेंट्स
है शायद वो भी होने चाहिए बट ठीक है जो भी
रिक्वायरमेंट होंगी वो इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा एंड ट्स इट ये
है हां अवेलेबल रहेगी यहां पर अब मैं करता
हूं अब मैं यहां पर एंटर करने की कोशिश
करता हूं लेट्स सी व्ट इज
[संगीत]
हैपनिंग
यस ओके यह स्टार्ट हो गई यहां पे एंड यहां
स्टार्ट हो गई अब देखो यहां पर देखो एक
टीडी का फाइल बना लिया ठीक है फायरिंग
स्कैन कैनन प्लीज कीप आर्म्स एंड लेग्स
इनसाइड द चेंबर एट ऑल टाइम्स एक्सक्लूड
कुछ है नहीं हमारे पास यहां प मासन
इंटीग्रेशन हुआ है अब ये देखो
16384 होस्ट्स को स्कैन कर रहा है
65536 पोर्ट्स पर होस्ट एक होस्ट के
स्कैनिंग में ये सारे पोर्ट्स को स्कैन
करेगा एक होस्ट के लिए और ऐसे 16000 होस्ट
है और ये सिर्फ अभी 0.05 पर डन हुआ है
सोचो टाइम कितना लगना है 19 घंटे इतने
मिनट 19 घंटे के लगभग लगेंगे ये भाई आपको
टाइम ऑन वीपीएस लोकल मशीन प करोगे तो क्या
होगा पता है वो भी मास्क स्कैन का यूज हो
रहा है य जो अपने आप में फास्ट है लोकल
मशीन पर करोगे तो क्या होगा पता है तुमको
वो टाइमिंग क्या क्या होगी कभी ट्राई करना
स्कैन करके अपने वीएम वेर या कहीं लोकल
मशीन पे समझ में आ
जाएगा दिमाग मतलब आराम से एक स एक वीक का
काम हम करके आओगे वापस तब तक कहीं हुआ
रहेगा 50 पर
शायद
हां इसको छोड़ दो ऐसे ही चलने दो इसमें
यही तो होता है यार अगर आपको कुछ फाइंड
करना है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें चलानी है
कुछ करना है ना तो ऐसे टाइम देना पड़ता है
इसको लगा दो एंड चलने दो ट्स इट 19 घंटे
यार एक वीक कहां लगेंगे यार 19 घंटे एक
दिन के अंदर हो जाएगा आपका तो इसको चला दो
एक दिन के लिए चलते रहने दो इसको सिंपल सा
फंडा है ट्स
इट हेलो भाई थोड़ा गाइड कर दो मैंने
नेटवर्किंग एंड लिनिक्स कर ली
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में c c+ प जावा अ
पाइथन ईटीसी आती है अभी क्या करूं रेड
टीमिंग जवाइन करना चाहता हूं अरे भाई
तुम्हें तो बहुत कुछ आता है भाई बहुत कुछ
आता है तुम्हें तो हमें तो कुछ भी नहीं
आता था इतना यू नो यू हैव अ ग्रेट नॉलेज
बहुत सारी चीजें आपको पता है ऑलरेडी पहले
आप एक फील्ड चूज करो कि आपको जाना किसमें
है आप जैसे बोल रहे हो रेड टीमिंग जवाइन
करना चाहता हूं तो बाकी चीजें आपकी
प्रोग्रामिंग जो स्किल्स है वो काम आ
जाएंगी रेट टीमिंग जब करोगे तो ओबवियसली
स्क्रिप्टिंग के ऑटोमेशन में काम आ जाएगा
बाकी जो आपकी चीजें हैं लाइक अ नेटवर्किंग
लिनिक्स जो की है वो बहुत सही की है
क्योंकि नेटवर्किंग की नॉलेज होनी बहुत
अच्छा बहुत अच्छा होता है बग बाउंटीज में
भी अगर आप हो वेब पन टेस्टिंग नेटवर्क पेन
टेस्टिंग कहीं पे भी आपका व यूज आ सकता है
उसके नॉलेज यूज आ सकती है लिनिक्स के
नॉलेज तो खैर मस्ट है तो अब आप रेड टीमिंग
के अकॉर्डिंग अपने आप को ढालो रेड टीमिंग
से रिलेटेड लैब्स को सॉल्व करो ट्राय हकमी
पे है हैक द बॉक्स यूज करो अलग-अलग तरह के
अ आर्टिकल्स आते हैं मीडियम पे उनको पढ़ो
इंफोसेक आर्टिकल्स हैं को पढ़ो एंड देन
ऑटोमेटिक आपको सारी चीजें समझ में आने लगी
पाथ जो है आपको पता चल जाएगा रेड टीमिंग
का ठीक है रेड टीमिंग बस अटैकर साइड है
यार हैकर का और कुछ नहीं
है क्या बात है तुम्हारा टैक पा घंटे में
ही फिनिश हो जाएगा क्या बात है बताओ यार
तुम कौन सा यूज करते हो भाई बहुत बढ़िया
बहुत गुड यहां पे तो आपको यह छोड़ना
पड़ेगा तो यह मैं आपको एक तरीका बता रहा
हूं कि आप इसका यूज करके बेसिकली व्हाट यू
कैन डू मैं यहां पे क्या बता रहा हूं कि
यू कैन स्कैन एंड यू कैन स्कन टायर
सीआईडीआर फॉर पर्टिकुलर टारगेट एंड वहां
से आपको बहुत कुछ मिल सकता है कुछ ना कुछ
तो मिलेगा भाई जब इतने घंटे यह चलेंगे तो
कुछ तो मिल ही जाएगा या चलने दो कोई बात
नहीं चलने
दो ठीक है तो मैं फिलहाल इसको मैं चलने
नहीं दूंगा फिलहाल तो मैं रोक दूंगा
क्योंकि कुछ ज्यादा ही टाइम
लगेगा सो यह थी आपकी स्कन कैनन तो हमने
बेसिकली आज क्या देखा मैं एक सराइज कर
देता हूं हमने यहां पर देखा ए
सर्विस
स्कैनिंग हमने यहां पर देखा एन
मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग एंजन हमने यहां पर एक
बेसिकली टूल यूज किया स्कैन कैनन नाम का
टूल ठीक है जो कि काफी इंटरेस्टिंग यली
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल था काफी बढ़िया था
उसके बाद हमने एक टूल यूज किया सड
मैप ठीक है इस टूल का हमने यूज किया एंड
देन लास्ट बस हमने बेसिकली यही काम किया
है एंड अ लिटिल बिट अ लिटिल बिट रिवीजन जो
हमने किया हुआ था ठीक है तो यह हमने किया
अब आपका टास्क क्या है वो टास्क आप देख लो
सबके
लिए टास्क है
आपका चूज अ
टारगेट ट्राई टू
गेट ऑल आईपी
एड्रेस रिलेटेड टू टारगेट और सी आईडिया
रेंज यूज एन मैप टू स्कैन फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स
यूज एन मैप या आप एन मैप के जगह पर मास
स्कैन या
नाबू या रस्ट
स्कैन यूज कर सकते हो
ओपन
पोर्ट्स ठीक है ये सारे काम कर सकते हो आप
रस्ट स्कन या जो भी आप यूज करना चाहते हो
कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है एन मैप का
यूज भी कर सकते हो अब जब आपने पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग कर ली है तो अब आपको सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन करनी
है तो यहां पे आप इसमें आप यह वाली भी टूल
यूज कर सकते हो स्कैन कैनन जो है ना स्कन
कैनन
यूज एन मैप या स्कैन कैनर फॉर सर्विस
डिटेक्शन ठीक है यह काम करता है यूज एन
मैप स्क्रिप्टिंग
इंजन जो कि आपका एनएससी होता है ट्स इट
ठीक है तो यह काम आपको सारा कुछ कर ये काम
जो है आपको कर लेना है ये ए टास्क है
प्लीज स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए आप लोग जो भी
है एंड जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया था गाइस
ट्राई हैक मी का आपको एन मैप का रूम
कंप्लीट करना है टास्क ठीक है एंड आपको
हमें टैग करना है
ओके एंड मैप को हम यहां समाप्त करते हैं
अब आगे से दूसरी लेबिलिटी और दूसरी चीजें
आने वाली है इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें तो मे बी
परसों में भी क्लास हो आपके तो उसके लिए
वेट कीजिए एंड बस
दैट्ची है यह हमारे लिंकडन पेज है आप मुझे
भी फॉलो कर सकते हैं नितेश सिंह यह वाली
आईडी है मेरी यहां पे टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
करके उसके बाद आप हमारी कंपनी की पेज है
डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी इसको जरूर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा इट्स वेरी इंपोर्टेंट हमारा
whatsapp2 हैकर बाय डेनिक्स तो यू विल
बिकम अ डीसी जेएसपी डिफ्रॉक सर्टिफाइड
जूनियर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल ओके
दैट्ची एंजॉयड द सेशन एंड थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन इन दिस ह्यूज नंबर मजा
आ गया आप लोग जितना उतना मजा आता है भाई
सच बता रहा हूं मैं ठीक है नेक्स्ट क्लास
की अनाउंसमेंट नेक्स्ट क्लास की डिटेल
आपको
सेशन के लिए इतना ही एंड सबको बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद ज्वाइन होने के लिए ऐसे ही बस बने
रहिए और शेयरिंग करते रहिए दोस्तों के भी
शेयर कीजिए अगर आपको थोड़ा भी फायदा होता
है थोड़ा भी बेनिफिट मिलता है तो एंड थैंक
यू सो मच मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
टाटा